Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Ausgabe von Raumzeit, dem Podcast, einem Projekt der ESA und des DLR. Und ja, heute geht es wie immer wieder einmal um einen größeren Themenkomplex, einen Ausschnitt aus dem Gesamtspektrum der deutschen und europäischen Raumfahrt. Und das Thema, was heute näher untersucht werden soll, ist Erdbeobachtung. Der Blick von oben auf unseren eigenen Planeten, nachdem wir auch schon mal so ein bisschen in die Ferne geschaut haben, kriegt mir jetzt den Blick einfach mal dahin, wo wir uns sowieso die ganze Zeit aufhalten und wo das Ganze auch eher mit täglichen und alltäglichen Problemen zu tun hat, als immer nur mit der Forschung als solcher. Ja, und als kompetenten Gesprächspartner begrüße ich Hans Joachim Lotz-Steven.
Hallo.
Du bist hier, also ich hab noch gar nicht gesagt, wo wir sind. Wir sind nämlich heute zu Gast bei den DLR in Oberpfaffenhofen, dem German Aerospace Center. Und ja, dein Institut heißt genau wie?
Das hat gerade einen neuen Namen bekommen.
Genau.
Und zwar sind wir das Erdbeobachtungszentrum oder im Englischen Earth Observation Center, EOC.
Okay, warum hat es einen neuen Namen bekommen?
Wir waren bisher ein Zusammenschluss von zwei Instituten mit sehr sperrigen Namen. Das eine war ein Institut für die Methodik der Fernerkundung, das andere das Deutsche Fernerkundungsdatenzentrum. Und das hat man, als das neue Gebäude für diese beiden Institute entstanden, sind zusammengefasst zu einem griffigeren Institutsnamen, Earth Observation Center, der lässt sich viel besser vermitteln als Cluster für angewandte Fernerkundung.
Okay, verstehe. Earth Observation Center, genau darum soll es ja auch gehen, die Erdbeobachtung. Überhaupt hat man so den Eindruck, dass hier auf diesem sehr großen Gelände einiges an Aktivität sich entfaltet, wird viel gebaut, wird viel errichtet. Ist der Eindruck richtig?
Absolut nicht. Hier wird seit einigen Jahren extrem viel gebaut. Es ist das neue Galileo-Kontrollzentrum entstanden. Es ist ein neuer Flugzeughanger für das Atmosphärenflugzeug des DLR entstanden, den HALO. Und es wird ein neues Gebäude entstehen für weitere Institute der Hochvergönstechnik. Dazu haben wir noch für die Robotik und Mechatronik ein neues Gebäude. Also wir sind am Expandieren.
Und man versteckt sich auch nicht. Hier steht in den nächsten Tagen ein Tag der offenen Tür an. Was passiert zu solchen Gelegenheiten?
Ja, da nehmen die Institute die Gelegenheit wahr, sich der Öffentlichkeit zu präsentieren. Das wird am nächsten Sonntag sein. Und durchschnittlich haben wir Besucherzahlen zwischen 4000 und 8000. Das hängt ein bisschen vom Wetter ab. Ich vermute mal, da der Sonntag gut werden soll, dass wir eher im oberen Bereich liegen werden. Und jedes Institut präsentiert sich mit seinen Arbeiten, auch mit interessanten Experimenten. Wobei das Programm auf dem Gelände dann auch bis hin zu Flügen reicht, die die Flugbereitschaft durchführt für Leute, die entsprechend zahlen oder auch Kinderprogramm.
Ja, dann hoffe ich, dass das eine unterhaltsame Veranstaltung wird für alle Beteiligten. Wie oft findet das statt? Ist das jedes Jahr?
Nein, das machen wir alle zwei Jahre. Wir hatten mal so einen jährlichen Turnus im Abwechseln mit dem Tag der Raumfahrt, aber das ist natürlich auch organisatorisch schon eine Belastung für die Mitarbeiter. Und dann hat man es jetzt im zweijährigen Turnus so eingefasst.
Okay, das heißt, die Leute, die das jetzt hier hören, werden wahrscheinlich keine Gelegenheit mehr haben, diesmal teilzunehmen, aber dann in zwei Jahren vielleicht noch mal. Gut. Erdbeobachtung, darum soll es gehen. Klingt jetzt erstmal ein bisschen unspektakulär, ist aber gar nicht so unspektakulär. Was umfasst das alles? Also man blickt von oben auf die Erde, warum tut man das? Wozu ist das gut?
Ja, die Erdbeobachtung, insbesondere die mit Satelliten, das ist ja unser Spezialgebiet, hat den Riesenvorteil, dass man sehr große Gebiete im Grunde genommen global, weil die Satelliten im Global aufnehmen, fassen kann mit solchen Satellitenmessungen und dass man relativ hohe Wiederholraten auch hat. Also wenn sie zum Beispiel mit dem Auto irgendwo hinfahren müssten, um in einem Land wie China oder Indien irgendeine Erdlichkeit zu besichtigen, einen Regenwald zu besichtigen, dann hätten sie kaum eine Chance mit dem Satelliten. Haben sie die Möglichkeit, alle Wochen oder Tage, je nachdem welches Satellitensystem sie nutzen, aktuelle Bilder von solchen Gegenden zu bekommen.
Wiederholrate.
Ja, Wiederholrate ist ein wichtiger Begriff, weil die Satelliten, je nachdem, wie sie technisch ausgelegt sind, das gleiche Gebiet eben in Zyklen von entweder 15 Minuten aufnehmen können oder auch, wenn es ganz Hochauflösende sind, dann Wiederholraten haben, die im Wochenbereich liegen. Und das ist oft eben sehr wichtig für die Anwendung. Denken Sie an einen Katastropheneinsatz. Da möchte man natürlich ständig in kurzen Abständen Informationen aktueller Art haben, welche Straßen sind noch befahrbar, wo sind Dinge verschüttet, wo sind Gebäude zerstört.
Man kann ja sagen, Erdbeobachtung ist quasi eng verflochten mit der Entwicklung von Satellitentechnik als solcher. Wobei es ja Erdbeobachtung wahrscheinlich auch schon vorher gegeben hat durch Flugzeuge. Findet das beim DLR auch statt?
Ja, wir haben auch Flugzeuge im Einsatz. Es gibt auch weiterhin auch, nachdem die Satellitentechnik sich derartig entwickelt hat in den letzten Jahrzehnten, gibt es weiterhin auch noch typische Anwendungen für Flugzeuge. Das Flugzeug hat eben die Möglichkeit, sehr dicht an der Erdoberfläche entlang zu fliegen, auch zum Teil unter den Wolken zu fliegen, was natürlich beim Satelliten nicht geht. Und deswegen wird das auch weiterhin hier betrieben. Weiterhin dienen die Flugzeuge dazu, Instrumente vorab zu testen, bevor sie in den Weltraum gehen und auf Satelliten eingesetzt werden.
Das heißt, das ist auch sozusagen ein Teil davon. Also koordiniert man sich da auch untereinander?
Ja, das ist zum Teil in den gleichen Instituten angesiedelt. Also gerade wenn ich auf unser Institut gehe, wir haben eine Abteilung, die sich speziell mit solchen Dingen beschäftigt, die eben auch eigene Sensoren entwickeln, die auf den Flugzeugen dann eingesetzt werden.
Wann hat denn das eigentlich so, kann man sagen, wann so das Thema Erdbeobachtung überhaupt das erste Mal sich so manifestiert hat?
Das hat auch stark mit der bemannten Raumfahrt zu tun. Als die ersten Bilder der Astronauten, die auf dem Mond waren, in der Presse sichtbar wurden, dieses eine Bild kennt wahrscheinlich jeder, wo diese schöne Erdkugel am Mondhorizont auftaucht und auch andere Fotos, die die Astronauten unterwegs gemacht haben, da war natürlich das Interesse groß, dass man die Erde von außen betrachtet und nicht nur aus diesem dichten Abstand, den man im Flugzeug hatte und dann wirklich diese globale Sicht plötzlich hatte. Und die ersten Anwendungen, die dann kamen und die ersten Satelliten, die gebaut wurden, waren Wettersatelliten, weil das natürlich das primäre Thema war, wenn man global schon misst, dann ist eben Wetter und Klima ein Hauptanwendungsthema. Nur war, wie du gerade sagtest, die Technik damals natürlich nicht die gleiche wie heute. Da hat man eben zum Teil auch noch mit Videokamera-Technik analog aufgenommen und auch analog runtergefunkt. Und der Schritt zum Digitalen ist dann eben erst in den nächsten Jahrzehnten erfolgt, weil die Rechner damals gar nicht so weit waren.
Ich kann sich gar nicht vorstellen, nicht wie dieses erste Bild der Erde so auf die Menschheit gewirkt haben muss. Also, den Blick gab es ja sozusagen vorher gar nicht. Man hatte ja eigentlich keine Ahnung.
Ja, es gab ja auch die Aussagen der Astronauten selber und auch später noch der Astronauten, die auf den Space Shuttle-Flügen waren bzw. auf der Raumstation sind, dass es sie emotional doch sehr, sehr berührt hat, wie man plötzlich diesen ganzen Planeten gesehen hat und auch diese sehr, sehr dünne Atmosphärenhülle, die ihn nach außen hin schützt, gesehen hat. Und die Verletzlichkeit dann erkennen konnte, die diesen Planeten halt doch auszeichnet.
Das macht man sich, glaube ich, auch mal relativ selten klar, was für ein unglaubliches Alleinstellungsmerkmal ist, der Erde in seiner ganzen nackten, kalten, bösartigen Umgebung des Weltraums. Das heißt, Wetter stand eigentlich am Anfang im Mittelpunkt. Kann man das so sagen?
Das kann man so sagen. Und wer sich zurückerinnert, auch vor 20, 30 Jahren gab es ja schon in den Nachrichtensendungen, wenn das Wetter der nächsten Tage verkündet wurde, diese Bilder vom Wetter-Satelliten Meteosat und später auch die kleinen Filmchen, die halt aus den halbstündigen Aufnahmen zusammenkomponiert worden waren, wo man die Entwicklung des Wetters sehen konnte. Und das waren die ersten Satelliten, die halt auch in diesen geostationären Bahnen geflogen sind. Vielleicht sollte ich das erläutern. Wenn ich immer die gleiche Aufnahme der Erdoberfläche machen will, dann muss ich eine Bahn wählen für den Satelliten, in der er sich mit der gleichen Umdrehungsgeschwindigkeit wie die Erde selbst dreht, sodass er für uns am Boden immer an der gleichen Stelle am Himmel steht. Das Gleiche gilt ja auch für die Fernsehsatelliten. Man möchte ja die Antenne nicht ständig nachführen. Diese Bahn ist dann allerdings extrem weit von der Erde weg. Das sind rund 36.000 Kilometer. Man muss sich mal vor Augen halten, dass diese Satelliten heutzutage aus der Entfernung Pixelgrößen liefern, die unter einem Kilometer sind. Wir sind momentan bei 500 Metern. Das ist schon sehr beeindruckend.
Also eine riesige Auflösung der Kameras, aber vor allem auch eine riesige Rauscharmut. Ist das das primäre Problem bei der? Ist das eine Frage der Optik? Ist das eine Frage, was macht es sozusagen so schwierig, aus dieser Distanz eine hohe Auflösung zu erzielen?
Man hat zum einen natürlich die Begrenzung durch die Auflösung der Optik, der Gläser, die in diesen optischen Apparaten verwendet werden. Die zweite Größe, die stark einen Einfluss auf die Bildqualität nimmt, ist natürlich der Einfluss der Atmosphäre. Denn das müssen wir bedenken. Es ist so, dass man im Allgemeinen die Sonne als Beleuchtungsquelle hat, die auf die Erde scheint. Die Sonne wird zunächst einmal durch die Atmosphäre beeinflusst. Und dann muss das reflektierte Licht ja wieder zurück zum Satelliten, geht wieder durch die Atmosphäre durch und wird entsprechend verfälscht, je nachdem, was dort für Komponenten in der Atmosphäre drin sind.
So wie der Blick ins Wasser eigentlich. Und das wird dann alles herausgerechnet?
Ja, es gibt Filter, Mechanismen, wo man bestimmte Dinge herausrechnen kann. Den Einfluss der Atmosphäre, man benutzt auch spezielle Spektralkanäle, um das zu bewerkstelligen. Die Frage ist natürlich immer, was interessiert einem. Es gibt natürlich die Meteorologen, die interessieren sich für die Atmosphäre und für den Einfluss der Atmosphäre, während die Anwender, die eher an der Landoberfläche interessiert sind, oder an der Vegetation oder an der Wasseroberfläche, die stören die Atmosphäre. Und für diese Anwendung hat es dann auch im Verlauf der letzten Jahrzehnte eine ganz neue Technik gegeben, die eben gar nicht mehr durch Wolken behindert wird, mit der man auch Nachtsbilder erzeugen kann. Und das war die Radartechnik. Da ist man eben nicht mehr auf die Sonne angewiesen, sondern man hat seine eigene Beleuchtungsquelle an Bord des Satelliten und beleuchtet damit die Erde. Und diese Radarstrahlen, die halt im Mikrowellenbereich angesiegelt sind, also Wellenlängen zwischen 3 und 60 cm etwa, die werden durch Wasserdampf nicht aufgehalten und können eben auch durch Wolken hindurchschauen.
Das heißt, aber da hat man ja sozusagen nicht den optischen Eindruck. Was sieht man denn dann mit dem Radar?
Das ist genau die Schwierigkeit bei der Interpretation der Bilder. Wir sind gewohnt, dass wir Bilder aus dem sichtbaren Licht vorgelegt bekommen. Das können wir interpretieren. Wir können die Farben interpretieren in diesen Bildern. Und wir tun uns schon schwer, wenn wir Infrarotbilder, die so im Bereich des nahen Infrarots sind, also das, was zum Beispiel eine Biene sehen würde, wenn sie eine Vegetationslandschaft betrachtet. Das können wir uns schon nicht mehr vorstellen, weil wir da keine Erfahrung haben mit unserem Sehapparat. Und noch drastischer wird diese Diskrepanz, wenn wir jetzt in den Mikrowellenbereich gehen. Weil dort die Reflektion dieser Mikrowellenstrahlen natürlich ganz anderen Einflüssen unterliegt. Wir müssen es nochmal gegeneinander halten. Wenn wir im optischen Bereich sind, dann haben wir Wellenlängen, die sind im Bereich von Nanometer, Mikrometern. Und wenn wir jetzt in den Mikrowellenbereich gehen, das sind Zentimeter. Und diese Zentimeterwellen werden ganz stark durch die Oberflächenstruktur des Objektes, das von den Strahlen getroffen wird, beeinflusst. Ich gebe mal ein Beispiel. Als wir die ersten Radar-Daten gesehen haben, waren plötzlich große Flächen mit weißen, dunklen, weißen, dunklen Linienstrukturen überzogen. Man hat sich gar nicht erklären können, was das denn gewesen sein könnte. In Wirklichkeit war es schlichtweg ein gepflügter Acker. Und da diese Radarstrahlen nicht senkrecht abgestrahlt werden von den Instrumenten, sondern leicht schräg, gibt es dann natürlich bei den Furchen, deren Flanke senkrecht zu auftreffen, dann Radarstrahlrichtung ist, eine starke Reflektion, während die abgewandte Seite überhaupt nicht reflektiert. Und deswegen hatten diese Bilder plötzlich diese Streifenmuster. Das sollte nur jetzt als Illustration dienen, dass die Interpretation eine völlig andere ist und dass man da sehr viel Erfahrung gewinnen muss, um rein visuell solche Bilder zu interpretieren.
Also so wie man immer so seine Farbtabelle im Kopf hat, mit grün sind Pflanzen und blau ist Wasser etc. und Landmasse ist halt braun, muss man hier sozusagen seine ganz eigene Farblandkarte entwerfen. Farben in Anführungsstrichen, also Frequenzlandkarte, welche Frequenzen und welche Abwechslung von Frequenzen, was genau bedeutet. Siehst du das richtig?
Das ist richtig so. Wir haben auch oft die Erfahrung gemacht, dass allein dadurch, dass die Farben vielleicht anders zugeordnet werden. Wenn man zum Beispiel Infrarotkanäle benutzt, statt rot-grün-blau Aufnahmen und diese Bilder dann plötzlich in der Farbe anders aussehen, dass also Wald plötzlich rot wird, dann sind viele Leute schon sehr irritiert, wenn sie so ein Bild vorgelegt bekommen und finden sich oft dann in einem Gelände, das sie eigentlich kennen müssten, nicht mehr auf dem Bild zurecht. Es gibt übrigens da auch eine historische Anknüpfung. Dieses Darstellen von Wald in rot, was man sehr oft bei solchen Satellitenbildern sieht, das stammt eben auch noch aus der Zeit, als man Infrarotfilm verwendet hat, in der Fernerkundung aus dem Flugzeug. Und damals wurden diese Bilder immer so entwickelt, dass eben der Infrarotkanal auf die rote Farbe im Bild gegeben wurde. Und das hat man so beibehalten, auch in der Satellitentechnik. Eigentlich würde man ja erwarten, dass man das auch auf grün gibt, sodass man eben grüne Vegetationen auch grün im Bild hat.
Weil es ja letztlich auch nur eine Interpretation der Frequenzbereiche ist. Da ist nichts rot, weil das ist ja ein ganz anderer Bereich.
Man stepp z.T. im Grunde genommen nur am Monitor die Kabel um, wenn man es mal so sieht. Man gibt dann rot auf grün und grün auf rot.
D.h. das ist jetzt einfach so ein Spaß irgendwie so, ah, da ist wieder mein Wald, den machen wir mal rot.
Ja, es hat schon ein bisschen den Hintergrund einmal, man wollte die Interpreten nicht verwirren, zum anderen ist es natürlich so, der weitere Vorteil der Satellitenfernerkundung besteht ja darin, dass ich nicht nur in dem sichtbaren Bereich aufnehmen kann, sondern es gibt ja Halbleitersensoren, die sind empfindlich für Naresinfrarot, für Mittleresinfrarot, für Thermisches, also Wärmeinfrarot und wenn ich das dann weiter treibe bis hin zu Mikrowelle, dann werden Satelliten gebaut, die haben Sensoren an Bord, die dieses gesamte Spektrum aufnehmen können. Und das heißt, ich kriege hinterher als Datensatz von den Satelliten Aufnahmen von vielleicht 10, 20, heutzutage sogar über 100 Spektralkanälen und dann habe ich die Wahl, wenn ich ein Bild herstellen will, welche von diesen Kanälen wähle ich aus und gebe die auf die drei Grundfarben des Monitors oder des entsprechenden Druckapparates, der mir einen Abzug erzeugt.
Das erzeugt dann wahrscheinlich eine sehr hohe Federtoleranz, nicht wahr? Weil was vielleicht in einem Frequenzbereich doppeldeutig ist, lässt sich durch die Reaktion in einem anderen Frequenzbereich deutlicher bestimmen?
Ich erkläre es mal andersherum. Was man ja wissen will bei der Fernerkundung, ist die Eigenschaft des Objekts, das ich hier beobachte. Wenn ich also zum Beispiel eine Biotopkartierung machen möchte. Also zum Beispiel...
Was lebt da?
Was lebt da? Welche Vegetation ist dort angesiedelt? Welche Getreidesorten, welche Pflanzen werden dort angebaut? Dann muss ich die spektralen Eigenschaften dieser Pflanzen vorher kennen. Das macht man so, indem man rausgeht ins Feld und mit einem Spektrometer einfach diese Pflanzen ausmisst und sozusagen einen spektralen Fingerabdruck erzeugt.
Und da ist jede Pflanze anders?
Da ist jede Pflanze anders. Und diesen spektralen Fingerabdruck speichert man im Rechner. Man weiß also, es ist eine gesunde, grüne Pflanze, absorbiert, ganz stark im roten Spektralbereich, reflektiert stark dem Grün. Deswegen empfinden wir sie ja auch als grün. Und hat auch eine ganz starke Reflektion im nahen Infrarot. Und so kann man sowohl für Pflanzen als auch für Gesteinsarten solche spektralen Signaturen sich auswählen.
Wenn sie nicht gesund ist, was verändert sich dann?
Wenn sie nicht gesund ist, dann verändert sich halt die Farbe. Das heißt, das Absorptionsverhalten der Pflanze ändert sich. Das Chlorophyll geht kaputt. Es wird nicht mehr so viel Rot aus dem weißen Sonnenlicht herausgezogen, sondern es wird mehr reflektiert und dadurch wird der Farbeindruck für uns vom Grünen in Richtung Gelb und Braun verschoben.
Verstehe. Und damit kann man dann relativ klar sagen, hier sind zwar Pflanzen, aber denen geht es wohl nicht so gut.
Ja, und das kann man zum Beispiel dann auch wieder hernehmen, um zu schauen, wie ist der Gesundheitszustand von Pflanzen. Das typische Anwendungsbeispiel war halt Kartierung von Waldschäden. Das wurde Mitte der 80er Jahre dann als ein Anwendungsthema auch sehr stark verfolgt. Und da hat man Satellitenmessungen hergenommen von Satelliten, die sieben Spektralkanäle aufgenommen haben. Und gerade diese Kombination der sichtbaren mit dem nahen und mittleren Infrarot war eben sehr, sehr interessant. Im mittleren Infrarot zum Beispiel kann man den Wassergehalt von Pflanzen ganz gut messen. Es ist also wirklich so, dass Satelliten auch konstruiert werden für ganz bestimmte Anwendungen. Dann werden die Anwender zurate gezogen, die sagen dann, wir sind Mineralogen, wir wollen Rohstoffe aufspüren. Und diese Gesteinsarten, in denen diese Rohstoffe hauptsächlich vorkommen, Kupferadern oder Uran oder was auch immer, haben ganz bestimmte spektrale Absorptions- und Reflektionseigenschaften. Und deswegen brauchen wir einen Sensor, der genau in dem Spektralbereich aufnimmt und einen anderen. Und so werden solche Satelliten dann auch konfiguriert.
Sind wir jetzt gerade so in den 80er Jahren, als das Waldsterben so ein großes Thema war, war das im Prinzip auch schon durch die aufkommende Erdbeobachtung unterstützte Diskussion?
Es war so, dass wir zu der Zeit, Mitte der 80er Jahre, die Satelliten zum einen in einer Auflösung schon hatten, die bis auf 30 bzw. 15 Metern pixel runter ging, sodass man dann auch kleinere Waldflächen untersuchen konnte. Vorher hatte man eben ganz grobe Raster, in denen das bei unseren Waldflächen sehr schlecht möglich gewesen wäre. Und dann war es natürlich ein schönes Anwendungsbeispiel, weil man eben diese Möglichkeiten der Multispektralaufnahmen dort voll ausnutzen konnte. Und man hat dann eben erste Erfahrungen damit gemacht. Als ich Mitte der 80er Jahre hier angefangen habe, hatten wir eine Gruppe, die war vernetzt mit vielen Universitäten und Forstbehörden, die genau das untersucht haben. Also welche Gebiete sind betroffen? Was kann man überhaupt herausfinden mit der Fernerkundung? Man muss ja da auch erst Erfahrung gewinnen. Und man darf auch nicht denken, dass die Fernerkundung aus dem Aal mit Satellitenbildern nun die einzige Informationsquelle ist. Man muss das immer koppeln mit dem, was man vor Ort gemessen hat und verifizieren. Denn Bildauswertung alleine bringt nicht ein Ergebnis, dass man jetzt mit einem Qualitätsziegel versehen könnte und sagt, das ist zu 95 Prozent sicher. Man muss immer am Boden verifizieren und das, was man als Ground Truth im englischen Bezeichnet durchführen.
Das heißt, umso genauer man schauen kann und vor allem umso mehr Frequenzbereiche man beobachtet, umso genauere Aussagen kann man über jeden Fleck auf dieser Erde machen. Was bringt das zum Beispiel, wenn man aufs Wasser guckt?
Beim Wasser ist zunächst mal ganz simpel die Farbe ein Informationsmerkmal. Man kann schauen auf das Wasser, wenn das Wasser eben sehr dunkelblau ist, kann man davon ausgehen, dass es ein relativ sauberes Wasser ist. Wenn es gelblich ist, kann man schon vermuten, dass es Elemente sein könnten, die dort reingeschwemmt worden sind. Wenn es andere Farben annimmt und vielleicht auch noch im Infraroten signalisiert, dass dort Vegetation ist, dann könnte man auf eine Algenblüte schließen und wenn man das genauer untersucht, kann man das auch relativ gut feststellen. Ich hatte vorhin erwähnt, dass inzwischen diese schmalbandigen Spektraaufnahmen im Kommen sind, dass also Satelliten mit über 200 ganz, ganz engbandigen Spektalkanälen gebaut werden und eingesetzt werden. Dann kann man natürlich nach ganz bestimmten Wasserinhaltsstoffen auch das Ganze untersuchen.
Also sozusagen konkrete Algentypen zum Beispiel, weil man eben wiederum deren Reflektions- oder Absorbtionsverhalten vorher analysiert und dann das entsprechend wiederfindet. Aber das geht dann sozusagen auch im Wasser. Also die schwimmen ja nicht unbedingt jetzt oben alle, oder? Es geht ja dann, wie tief kann man denn reinschauen in das Wasser?
Ja, das ist natürlich nur die obere Schicht. Also wenn sie jetzt zum Beispiel Temperatur messen wollen vom Wasser und setzen ein Infrarot-Sensor dafür ein, dann kriegen sie nur die obersten zwei Zentimeter. Aber sie haben sehr, sehr hohe Temperaturauflösung. Also sie bekommen die Temperatur sehr genau, bis auf Zehntelgrad genau. Das wird zum Beispiel eingesetzt, indem man Phänomene wie den El Nino schon voraussagen kann, weil man eben diese globale Erfassung der Meerestemperaturen hat. Man sieht die großen Strömungen, man sieht die Temperatur der großen Strömungen, kann dann eben sofort feststellen, aha, in diesem Jahr fällt dieser kalte Humboldt-Sturm an der Westküste von Südamerika zusammen, das Wasser wird wärmer. Und man sieht auch, wie das von Indonesien aus zurück schwappt, dieses heiße Wasser, und kann dann eben schon vorab sagen, dass es eben in diesem Jahr wieder einen El Nino geben wird. Also diese Voraussagen funktionieren inzwischen schon sehr gut.
Also man kriegt Temperatur, man kriegt die Inhaltsstoffe. Wie bildet sich denn zum Beispiel so die Ölkatastrophe, die im Golf jetzt zu beklagen war, durch diese explodierte Bohr-Plattform? Wie könnte man das untersuchen? Wird das untersucht? Wird das beobachtet, wenn ja wie?
Zum einen natürlich, indem man die Oberfläche selbst im Optischen abtastet. Man sieht dann halt diese dunklen Flecken und Schlieren. Zum anderen aber auch mit der Radartechnik. Gerade die Radartechnik bietet ja die Möglichkeit, auch die Oberflächen-Rauigkeit zu erfassen, weil eben die Wellenlängen im Bereich dieser Oberflächen-Rauigkeit liegen. Ich hatte vorhin gesagt, das sind zum Beispiel 3 cm Wellenradars. Und wenn so eine Öllache auf einer Wasseroberfläche liegt, dann ist natürlich die Rauigkeit in diesem Bereich wesentlich geringer, als wenn ich jetzt ein bewegtes Meer habe. Das heißt, ich sehe sofort auf diesen Bildern dunkle Flecken, denen ich Öl zuordnen kann, wenn ich weiß, dass dies wahrscheinlich der Grund sein wird. Mit der Technik kann man zum Beispiel auch sehr gut feststellen, dass irgendwelche Öltanker auf ihrer Route die Tankslärger waschen haben und dann so eine Ölspur hinter sich herziehen. Das wird auch verwendet, um zum Beispiel Lecks bei Ölplattformen relativ frühzeitig festzustellen, indem man regelmäßig diese Gebiete oder diese Plattformen überwacht vom Satelliten, aber auch vom Flugzeug aus.
Und überwacht sozusagen wirklich jetzt jemanden regelmäßig alle Bohrplattformen, weil es wird ja gemutmaßt, dass eine ganze Menge Öl so austritt bei diesen ganzen Bohrplattformen.
Also ich weiß, dass die Norweger das auf jeden Fall machen mit ihren Plattformen. Es ist ja auch ein wirtschaftlicher Verlust, wenn der Ölaustritt ist. Man muss es ja nicht nur unter Umweltgewichtspunkten betrachten.
Jaja klar, jedes Öl, was davon schwimmt, kann nicht mehr verkauft werden. Das stimmt. Also es ist sozusagen im Eigeninteresse und wird von daher dann auch beauftragt, aber dann von privaten Firmen vorgenommen oder wird es auch staatlich?
In diesem Falle privat. Die meisten RALA-Satelliten sind allerdings momentan noch in der Hand der großen Raumfahrtorganisation beziehungsweise in solchen private public partnerships, wie zum Beispiel beim deutschen Satelliten TerraSatX betrieben, wo also öffentliche Hand und die Firmen zusammenarbeiten.
Auf den Bereich, wenn wir sicherlich auch gleich nochmal separat zu sprechen kommen, bleiben wir nochmal kurz bei dem, was man alles überhaupt so sehen kann. Ich finde das gerade ganz spannend. Ist denn nicht auch vorstellbar, dass diese Techniken auch für die Archäologie zum Einsatz kommen?
Ja, da gibt es durchaus Ansätze. Zum einen, ich komme nochmal auf das Radar zurück, das mit den langen Wellenlängen natürlich eine gewisse Eindringtiefe in den Boden erbringt. Und wenn der Boden jetzt nicht stark leitfähig ist, sondern zum Beispiel wie in Wüstengebieten schwach leitfähig ist, dann kann ich unter die Sandoberfläche die Felsformationen erkennen oder auch Gebäude erkennen, die unter der reinen Sandoberfläche verborgen sind.
Was beeinflusst diese Leitfähigkeit? Ist das einfach der Mangel an Wasser an der Stelle?
Feuchtigkeit zum Beispiel, ja. Oder andere leitfähige Materialien. Also trockener Sand ist natürlich sehr wenig leitfähig. Aber selbst in humiden Gebieten, also Gebieten mit Vegetationsoberfläche, paust sich eine unterirdische Bauanlage oft nach oben durch, indem der Bewuchs dort, wo Mauern sind, einfach dünner ist. Und es gibt sogar gewisse Getreidesorten, die besonders empfindlich sind auf die Untergrundfeuchtigkeit und dort in dem Bereich dann eben schlechter wachsen, sodass man, wenn man diese Felder überfliegt, mit einem Flugzeug, mit entsprechendem Sensor, Wärmesensor oder mittler aus Infrarot, dass man dort auch sehen kann, dass dort regelmäßige Strukturen drunter sind, die man Gebäuden zuordnen kann.
Aha. Und ist das jetzt immer nur so Zufallsfunde oder wird tatsächlich die Archäologie auch, also gibt es sozusagen auch regelmäßige Suche nach solchen Funden?
Doch, es gibt durchaus dort ein Fachgebiet, das sich speziell damit befasst. Und man hat natürlich früher mit Flugzeugen angefangen, das zu machen und benutzt heute auch Satellitenaufnahmen.
Und Atlantis? Ist es irgendwie noch zu finden?
Ich hatte einen Kollegen, der wollte das finden mit Radaraten. Aber damit er nicht fest die Örtlichkeit schon mal eingrenzen kann, ob das nur in einem bestimmten Bereich des Mittelmeeres oder des Atlantiks liegt, wird er wahrscheinlich wenig Glück haben.
Okay. Aber wenn man genauere Anhaltspunkte bekommt, dann wäre das unter Umständen auch... Aber ins Wasser, der Meeresgrund ist als solcher gar nicht zu erreichen. Wenn man von oben schaut, bleibt man im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes an der Oberfläche.
Direkt nicht, allerdings indirekt. Weil je nachdem, wie tief das Wasser ist, natürlich die Anziehungskraft des darunterliegenden Gesteins, der Erde selber, einen Einfluss auf die Höhe der Wasseroberfläche hat. Es ist ja so, dass die Gravitation sehr unterschiedlich ist. Die Erde ist ja keine Kugel, auch keine Ellipsoid, sondern diese berühmte Kartoffel, die Sie bestimmt schon gesehen haben. Und das kommt eben dadurch, dass die Masseverteilung in der Erde selber und die Landwasserverteilung nicht gleichmäßig ist. Und man kann durch Satellitenmessungen die Höhe der Meeresoberfläche sehr, sehr genau bestimmen, indem man sehr, sehr viele Messungen hernimmt. Und wenn ich zum Beispiel Radarsensoren habe, dann messe ich einfach die Laufzeit des Signals vom Radaranbord des Satelliten runter zur Erde und wieder zurück aus und kann daraus die Entfernung ausrechnen, wenn ich den Orbit sehr genau kenne. Und die Orbitposition des Satelliten, die kann ich bis auf Zentimeter genau bestimmen. Und in den Bereichen, in denen jetzt die Anziehungskraft des darunter liegenden Gesteins unter der Wasseroberfläche gering ist, wird das Wasser natürlich höher sein als in Bereichen, wo darunter sehr viel Felsen ist und dort wird das Wasser tiefer sein. Also ich kann schon jetzt die Gravitationswirkung des Gesteins und damit natürlich auch die Meerestiefe bestimmen. Und solche bathymetrischen Messungen, also Höhenmessungen des Meeresgrundes, haben dann eben auch globale Bilder der Erde ohne Wasser zur Folge.
Warum? Also mir ist nicht ganz klar, ob da nun Gestein oder Wasser ist. Das ist doch eigentlich egal.
Die spritzistische Dichte bestimmt ja die Anziehungskraft, also die Masse selber. Und Wasser hat halt eins und Gestein kann durchaus erheblich mehr haben.
Okay, gut. Und solche Unterschiede sind da schon bestbar.
Die Unterschiede sieht man dann auf der Meeressoberfläche.
Okay, das heißt, so eine Tiefenkartografie ist quasi allein schon mit dem Blick von außen theoretisch oder auch praktisch machbar. Und ist auch schon gemacht worden?
Die ist auch gemacht worden. Es gibt auch noch eine andere Möglichkeit, wie man das Gravitationsfelden, damit die Gestalt der Erde messen kann. Man schickt dort sehr, sehr kleine Satelliten, so können Sie sich vorstellen, diese Disco-Lichtkugeln mit diesen Spiegelflächen in das Weltall und vermisst die Bahn dieser Kleinstsatelliten mit Lasermessungen von der Erde. Hier ist wieder genau das gleiche Prinzip. Wenn die um die Erde kreisen, werden sie an Gebieten, wo sie über ein sehr starkes Gravitationsfeld drüberfliegen, ein bisschen runtergezogen in ihre Bahn. Wenn sie wieder in schwächer Gravitationsregionen kommen, driften sie ein bisschen weiter nach außen. Wenn man die Bahn genau vermisst, kann man das anschließend zurückrechnen auf den Erddurchmesser und kann so praktisch die Gestalt des Erdmessers.
diese Diskokugel muss die ganze Zeit mit einem Laser angestrahlt werden.
Die müssen von verschiedenen Laserstationen auf der Erde, wenn sie die Erde umrunden. Das sind sehr viele von diesen Kugeln. Die werden ständig ausgemessen, die Bahnen. Dort kann man sehr genau auch das Schwerfeld der Erde bestimmen.
Das ist ja ein sehr eleganter Ansatz. Aber das prägt wahrscheinlich auch die Erdbeobachtung. Man muss sich eigentlich eine ganze Menge einfallen lassen, um sozusagen den Details auf die Spur zu kommen.
Ja, vor allen Dingen braucht man immer das Fachwissen der entsprechenden Anwender. Das ist eben auch ein interessanter Aspekt der Beschäftigung mit diesen Satellitendaten, dass man nicht immer nur mit dem gleichen Thema befasst ist, sondern das reicht dann eben von der Klimauntersuchung, vom globalen Wandel bis hin zur Regional- und Stadtplanung, wo man eben solche Daten hernimmt, um zu schauen, wo kann man Industriegebiete ansiedeln, wie ist das Stadtklima beschaffen, wo dürfen keine Baugebiete ausgewiesen werden, weil die Frischluftzufuhr sonst verhindert wird. Es reicht von der Geologie bis hin zur zivilen Sicherheit und Katastrophenhilfe. Also man hat immer wieder mit ganz anderen Leuten und ganz anderen Fachgebieten zu tun. Und das macht das Ganze auch sehr abwechslungsreich.
Ja, Stichwort urbane Regionen. Jetzt denkt man ja bei Erdbeobachtungen immer so an die Natur. Hat man jetzt auch schon. Die Meere, die Verschmutzung bzw. überhaupt die Eigenschaften, die Vegetation. Inwiefern, was sieht man, was kann man sehen, wenn man sich die Städte genauer anschaut?
Man kann natürlich zunächst einmal die Versiegelung solcher großen Flächen, insbesondere bei den ganz großen Städten, den Megacities, beobachten. Man kann bei Städten auch inzwischen durch solche Radarmessungen Gebäude Höhen ganz gut kartieren. Was zum Beispiel sehr interessant ist für Mobilfunkanwendung oder auch für Flugführerunterstützung. Es ist ja so, dass ein normales digitales Höhenmodell der Erde immer nur die idealisierte Erdoberfläche darstellt, aber nicht die Gebäude drin hat und auch nicht die Vegetationshöhe drin hat. Und wenn ich ein solches dreidimensionales Modell aus Satellitenmessungen habe, wo eben so ein Radarstrahl reflektiert wird, dann wird er natürlich immer am ersten Objekt, das er trifft, reflektiert. Das heißt, in einem durch Radarmessungen erzeugten digitalen 3D-Modell der Erdoberfläche habe ich alle diese Objekte mit drin, sodass bei schlechter Sicht auch ein Flugzeugpilot die Möglichkeit hat, wenn er so ein 3D-Modell eingespielt hat in seinem Flugzeug, die echte Höhe über Objekten festzustellen. In Städten kann man natürlich, was ich vorhin erwähnte, diese Stadt Klimaplanung gut machen. Man hat die Möglichkeit, auch die Gesundheit von Grünanlagen zu kartieren. Es gibt zum Beispiel hier in München für den Stadtbereich ein Baumkataster, das eben aus Fernerkundungsdaten gewonnen wurde, in dem eben wirklich Stadtplanung betrieben wird, wo sind die Bäume, in welchem Gesundheitszustand, wo muss neu angepflanzt werden, wo müssen Bäume gefällt werden. Also das ist inzwischen ein fester Bestandteil der meisten Planungsinstrumente.
Warum müssen die Bäume dann gefällt werden?
Wenn sie sehr krank sind, stellen sie natürlich eine Gefahr da für den Verkehr, der vielleicht direkt an der Allee entlanggeht.
Achso, okay, einfache praktische Gründe. Lass dich denn dann sozusagen, ich meine, es müsste sicher eigentlich auch sehr ordentliches Wärme- und Lichtemissionsbild einer Stadt erzeugen lassen. Kann man da Rückschlüsse auf Isolation von Gebäuden etc. schließen? Oder ist das, strahlt eine Stadt insgesamt viel zu sehr Licht und Wärme ab, als dass man das noch einzeln differenzieren könnte?
Ich denke mal, Gebäude selber, einzelne Gebäude zu kartieren aus dem All ist ein bisschen übertrieben. Das macht man sicherlich vor Ort besser, weil in Stadtregionen kommt man ja ohnehin vor Ort hin. Was auf jeden Fall gemacht wird, ist, ganze Stadtregionen mit Wärmekameras zu detektieren. Das hat man früher mit Flugzeugen gemacht, weil bei den Satelliten die räumliche Auflösung nicht gut genug war. Das macht man aber heute auch mit Satelliten. Die typischen Aufnahmen sind dann eben, dass man eine Aufnahme hat, die aus der Zeit der stärksten Abkühlung, also morgens sehr früh, irgendwie 4 Uhr in der Gegenkarte, und dann in der höchsten Aufheizung. Und dann kann man über Modelle, die es bereits gibt, dann Luft-Zirkulationsflüsse berechnen und zum Beispiel so statt klimarelevante Steuerungsmaßnahmen ergreifen. Also zum Beispiel sagen, hier müssen wir eine Grünfläche ausweisen, weil so eine Grünfläche produziert kühle Luft und hier dürfen wir auf keinen Fall zubauen, weil dort die Zufuhr von frischer Luft aus dem Umland sonst verhindert werden würde. Und was die Helligkeit angeht, aus der Helligkeit kann man natürlich auch Rückschlüsse ziehen auf den Energieverbrauch. Und gerade wenn man das mit globalen Aufnahmen macht, kann man sehr schön sehen, wie die großen Städte nachts sehr hell leuchten, wie Industrieanlagen oder auch Ölförderungsanlagen, wo abgefackelt wird, sehr stark in diesen Bildern zu sehen sind. Und man kann durchaus größenordnungsmäßig abschätzen, wie viel Energie dort wirklich verbraucht wird.
Tatsächlich? Allein von dem?
Ja, es gibt Anhalts. Also jetzt, ich meine, über die Neuigkeit würde ich jetzt keine Aussage machen. Aber es ist sicherlich ein Anhaltspunkt.
Ja klar, ich meine, wenn da viel Licht ist, dann muss da auf jeden Fall erst mal Energie umgesetzt werden, sonst wäre da nicht viel Licht nachvollziehbar. Ja, das war jetzt, okay, jetzt haben wir ein sehr großes Spektrum gesehen, wie sich Erdbeobachtung so darstellen kann. Haben wir denn in irgendeinem wichtigen Bereich jetzt hier in dieser Aufzählung komplett übersehen, der sozusagen hier noch mit reinspielt, also von den möglichen Anwendungen?
Ja, ich hatte vorhin ganz am Anfang, als wir über die Anfänge sprachen, gesagt, die Meteorologie, das war so der Treiber am Anfang dieser Erdbeobachtung. Und als die Sensoren dann immer besser wurden, immer höher aufgelöst wurden, dann kamen so die typischen Anwendungen dazu, dass man sagte, wir wollen Vegetation, Landnutzung, Landoberfläche kartieren. Ein typisches Anwendungsbeispiel war Ernteabschätzung. Da macht man eben Satellitenbildauswertung aus der Wachstumsphase im Frühjahr und versucht daraus, Abschätzungen zu machen, wie wird die Ernte im Herbst ausfallen. Das waren Auflösungen der Bilder, die man dort schon zur Verfügung hatte, die in dem Bereich von 20, 30 Metern raken, wo man eben auch in Deutschland die Feldgrößen noch einigermaßen gut mit erfassen kann. Und als dann die Satelliten immer besser wurden in der Auflösung bis hin zu 1-Meter-Pixeln oder sogar Sub-Meter-Pixeln, inzwischen sind wir bei 50 Zentimetern etwa angelangt im zivilen Bereich, kamen plötzlich ganz neue Anwendungen dazu, die man früher nur mit Flugzeugsensorik bewältigt hat. Und eine ganz, ganz neue Gruppe von Anwendungen, die kamen jetzt erst seit den letzten 10, 15 Jahren zum Tragen. Und das sind Katastrophenhilfe und zivile Sicherheit. Und da war es vor allen Dingen wichtig bei Katastrophenhilfe, dass man zeitnah, also near real time, sozusagen ausgewertete Bildinformationen den Helfern vor Ort zur Verfügung stellen kann. Und das ist keine einfache Aufgabe.
Wie sieht das dann konkret aus? Also ein Beispiel, wo es sicherlich zum Einsatz kam, war das Erdbeben in Haiti.
Ja, da waren wir schon ganz gut eingespielt. Ich gehe vielleicht nur noch mal auf die Anfänge zurück. Das grundsätzliche Problem, was man da hat, ist ja immer, man muss erst mal wissen, welche Aufnahmen stehen denn überhaupt aus diesem Gebiet zur Verfügung. Und es gibt zwar eine ganze bekannte Liste von Satellitenbetreuern. Und man weiß auch, welche Satelliten im Grunde genommen dafür in Frage kämen. Man muss aber auch den genauen Aufnahmeplan dieser Satelliten kennen, um sehr frühzeitig zu wissen, wo kann ich Daten ordern. Und es gibt inzwischen eine Charter on Major International Disasters. Das ist ein Zusammenschluss von Satellitenbetreuern und Weltraumorganisationen und Firmen, die sie verpflichtet haben, bei solchen großen internationalen Einsätzen, bei Katastrophenhilfe zusammenzuarbeiten und Daten umsonst zur Verfügung zu stellen. Der erste Schritt ist dann, das betroffene Gebiet stellt den Hilfeantrag bei diesem Büro. Dann wird ein Koordinator benannt und dieser Koordinator fängt dann sofort an zu arbeiten und fordert von allen Satellitenbetreibern, von denen er weiß, dass sie Daten liefern könnten, die Daten an. Diese Daten werden dann kostenlos bereitgestellt, werden bei diesem Koordinator bearbeitet, aufbereitet und es werden Karten hergestellt, die dann per Funk an die betroffenen Regionen bzw. an die Hilfskrise dort zur Verfügung gestellt werden. Man muss also eine genaue Flugplanung und Aufnahmeplanung aller Satelliten haben, das bekommt man heutzutage von den Betreibern, das haben wir dann auch installiert. Und man muss sich auskennen mit der Verarbeitung unterschiedlichster Datentypen, muss die auch so aufbereiten, dass die Bilder aufeinander passen und die Informationen, die man hat, muss das überlagern mit Karteninformationen. Denn das Produkt, das man dann an die Hilfskräfte rausgibt, das muss so sein, dass sie es auch verstehen. Und in vielen Fällen ist immer noch die gedruckte Papierkarte mit einer Legende dazu das Medium, was am meisten angefordert wird. In Zukunft wird das wahrscheinlich anders aussehen. Dann wird man die Dinge alle virtuell realisieren können in 3D. Das ist also jetzt momentan so die Zielrichtung, in dem wir gehen wollen, sodass dann diese Information direkt auf die Computer der Häfer vor Ort eingespielt wird und die sich in einem 3D-Raum bewegen können und sehen können, wo sind jetzt Straßen zerstört worden, wo sind Erdrutsche, wo sind Gebäude zerstört und wo sind noch Krankenhäuser, die man anfahren könnte. Das wäre eben so eine Zusatzinformation, die in so einen Satellitenbildkarte mit hineinprojiziert werden kann. Das ist eben gerade in Katastrophensituationen eine ganz ganz wertvolle Hilfe, weil dort normalerweise Chaos herrscht und eben auch alle verfügbaren Flugzeuge und Hubschrauber im Einsatz sind. Und da ist es schön, wenn man eine außenstehende Quelle von Informationen hat, die einem versorgt.
Seit wann gibt es diese Charter? Seit wann sind die so?
Die Charter gibt es jetzt schon seit mindestens zehn Jahren, glaube ich. Und wir haben dort schon sehr viele Einsätze für die Charter gemacht, obwohl wir noch nicht offizielles Mitglied waren. Sind das gerade jetzt in der letzten Woche geworden, haben den Vertrag unterzeichnet. Und haben inzwischen diese Reaktionszeit, also die Zeit zwischen dem Anruf des Büros, dass eine Katastrophe passiert ist, bis hin zur Auslieferung der ersten Karten verkürzen können. Am Anfang war es noch fast eine Woche. Inzwischen sind wir runter bis auf eineinhalb Tage oder einen Tag. Das ist fix, denn es müssen sehr große Datenmengen bewegt werden. Das war eben früher oft das Problem, dass man die Daten einfach nicht heranschaffen konnte. Wenn wir von Satellitendaten, also von Rasterbilddaten reden, dann sind das natürlich immer gleich Größenordnungen im Bereich mehrere Hundert Megabyte, die da hin- und hergeschoben werden müssen über Netzwerk. Das kann sich dann ganz schön aufsummieren.
Ich schau gerade mal in die Historie von der Charter. Da sind ja schon ganz schön viele Aktivierungen. Wir reden hier nicht von ein, zwei international wahrgenommenen Katastrophen pro Jahr, sondern das ist so, alle paar Tage passiert irgendetwas. Hier eine Flut, da ein Erdbeben, hier ein Sturm und natürlich auch hier der Oil-Spill, Golf of Mexico, den wir schon erwähnt haben, Hurricanes. Oha. Pakistan natürlich 2010, Riesenkatastrophe. Das heißt, das sieht hier schon so aus, als ob so über das Jahr so auf 30, 40 Einsätze kommen kann.
Deswegen auch dieser internationale Zusammenschluss. Und es gibt auch so ein bisschen was wie saisonale Höhepunkte. Also typischerweise im Sommer gibt es die Waldbrände. Dann gibt es in den Wintermonaten oft die Überschwemmungen. Und gerade Waldbrände sind auch ein sehr gutes Beispiel dafür, was Fernerkundung leisten kann. Denn bei Waldbränden kommt die Möglichkeit wieder zum Vorschein, dass man mit ganz spezifischen Sensoren eben solche, wie wir das nennen, Hochtemperaturereignisse gut detektieren kann. Ich erkläre es vielleicht mal, was damit gemeint ist. Jeder kann sich vielleicht noch an die Physikunterrichtsstunde über das Blankste Strahlungsgesetz erinnern, das sagt, dass jeder Körper, der nicht die Temperatur 0 hat, also 0 Kelvin hat, elektromagnetische Strahlung aussendet. Und die Art dieser Strahlung, die Intensität und auch das Maximum, bei welcher Frequenz das passiert, hängt eben von der Temperatur ab. Die Sonne strahlt zum Beispiel mit 5600 Kelvin und die strahlt alles ab, von harter UV-Strahlung bis hin zu Radiowellen. Und das Maximum liegt im sichtbaren Bereich. Das ist also so eine Gaussverteilung, die am hinteren Ende ein bisschen flacher ausläuft. Das Maximum liegt im sichtbaren Bereich, also im sichtbaren Licht, rot-grün-blau. Wenn ich jetzt ein Feuer habe, das aktiv brennt, ein Waldbrand zum Beispiel, dann hat der eine Temperatur so etwa um die 1000 Grad. Und das Maximum der Strahlung, die von diesem Feuer ausgeht, liegt dann nicht im sichtbaren Licht, sondern das liegt im mittleren Infrarot. Und deswegen erkenne ich Feuer sehr viel besser in einer Satellitenaufnahme aus dem mittleren Infrarot als im sichtbaren. Weil im sichtbaren Licht habe ich auf den Rauch von oben, der mir die Sicht auf die eigentliche Brandquelle versperrt. Und deswegen werden solche Feuerdetektoren eben im mittleren Infrarot arbeiten. Und es gibt inzwischen auch einen Feuerservice, den wir betreiben. Da werden automatisch jeden Tag die Daten verschiedener Satelliten, die eben großflächig aufnehmen, ausgewertet. Und es wird dieser mittlere Infrarotkanal zum Beispiel hergenommen, um zu schauen, wo sind da Hotspots, also Pixel- oder Pixelverbünde, die sehr stark aus ihrer Umgebung hervorstechen, weil sie einen starken Helligkeitsunterschied haben. Und das wird dann noch mit ein paar anderen Verarbeitungsmethoden zusammen hinterher zu einer aktuellen Feuerkarte zusammengestellt. Und das können Sie im Internet kostenlos sich jeden Tag anschauen. Sie können also wirklich die aktuelle Feuersituation in ganz Europa auf einen Blick täglich, ich glaube zweimal, zwei- oder dreimal täglich wird das erneuert, sich anschauen.
Wo im Internet?
Das ist zum Beispiel bei uns in dem Internetportal des Zentrums für satellitengestützte Kriseninformationen eingebettet und gehört zu einem Service, den wir zusammen betreiben mit der brasilianischen Conabio. Das ist die brasilianische Organisation, die eben auch Satellitenbildauswertung macht. Und es gibt noch weitere Organisationen, die ähnliche Services anbieten, weil es relativ einfach zu rechnen geht auch. Und das ist schon mal eine wertvolle Hilfe. Das zweite, was man noch machen kann...
Warum gerade die Kooperationen mit den Brasilianern?
Na gut, die Brasilianer haben natürlich das Problem der Waldbrände. Und die haben den Anlass, das in der Form...
Vor allem jetzt auch nicht nur Waldbrände mit natürlichem Ursprung sein, eben auch Rodungen.
Ja, genau. Das wollen sie ja detektieren und kartieren und überwachen vor allen Dingen. Und das zweite, was man noch machen kann, man kann sogar anhand der unterschiedlichen Temperatur von aktiven Feuern und Regionen, wo das Feuer schon ein bisschen zurückgegangen ist, wo eher so Schwelbrände noch existieren. Das kann man eben dann sehr gut unterscheiden, wenn man Sensorien hat, die eben in diesen benachbarten Spektalbereichen, in denen diese beiden 1000 Grad, vielleicht 400 oder 500 Grad heißen Regionen sich noch unterscheiden lassen. Das heißt, man kann hier direkt den Helfern vor Ort eine Karte geben, wo sie sehen können, da sind die wirklich aktiven Regionen, da muss jetzt primär was getan werden und da ist es schon mehr oder weniger runtergegangen. Das können wir momentan vernachlässigen. Und das haben wir eben intensiv in den letzten Jahren in Spanien und Portugal auch mit unterstützt.
Lässt sich dann auch schon eine Vorhersage machen? Also ich meine, lassen sich sozusagen auch Waldbrand-Wahrscheinlichkeiten, also jetzt auf Basis natürlichen Ursprungs natürlich, also große Trockenheiten, müssten sich ja im Prinzip auch ablesen lassen aus der Erprobung.
Ich will es mal ein bisschen allgemeiner formulieren. Solche Risk-Models oder Risk-Karten, die versucht man herzustellen. Bei Waldbränden ist es vielleicht ein bisschen schwierig, weil viele Waldbrände entstehen entweder durch Brandstiftung oder durch Blitzeinschlag. Das kann man natürlich nicht vorhersagen.
Aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es dann...
Die Trockenheit natürlich. Das ist ja sowieso eingebettet in das grundsätzliche Thema Bodenqualität. Und das ist eines der großen Themen, die jetzt in der Zukunft wahrscheinlich im Kontext globaler Wandel oder Änderung des globalen Klimas eine Rolle spielen, werden Bodenqualität und Wasserqualität. Dieses ZKI, dieses Zentrum für krisengeschützte Kriseninformationen, das ist entstanden... Das ist recht neu. Ja, das ist entstanden aus den ersten Einsätzen im Rahmen dieser Charter for major international disasters. Und nachdem wir gemerkt hatten, dass wir hier eigentlich gute Erfolge erzielt haben und eben auch entsprechend von den Organisationen, die wir da mit Informationen beliefert hatten, immer wieder angefordert wurden, haben wir beschlossen, das zu einem Service auszubauen. Und haben dieses ZKI dann eben ausgebaut. Und das gehört inzwischen hier im Erdbeobachtungszentrum zu einer wesentlichen Komponente, zu dem EOC Service Lab. Da gibt es noch zwei weitere Komponenten drinnen. Das eine ist das World Data for Atmospheric Data. Und das dritte ist eine Referenzplattform, in der wir zum Beispiel Steuerungssoftware für das Tsunamiwarnsystem, das wir mit den Indonesien zusammen aufbauen, erstellt haben.
Inwiefern kann man beim Tsunami die Erdbeobachtung einsetzen?
Das ist eine interessante Frage. Die ich auch gerne beantworte. Das Problem beim Tsunami ist ja diese extrem kurze Zeit, die man hat, um zu reagieren. Das was man gelernt hat aus der Katastrophe in Indonesien war, dass man zwar sehr viel Informationen aus unterschiedlichen Quellen hat, dass diese Informationen aber nicht zusammengeführt werden konnte. Deswegen war die Grundidee bei diesem Tsunamiwarnsystem ein System zu schaffen, in dem jegliche Informationsquelle sofort eingespeist wird. Wenn also irgendwo ein unterirdisches Erdbeben, also ein Seebeben passiert, das eine Tsunamiwelle auslösen könnte, dann ist die erste Information die der Seismografen. Das heißt, diese seismografischen Instrumente, die ja weltweit verteilt sind, liefern als erstes ein...
Unter Wasser.
Unter Wasser, aber auch auf Land, liefern eine Information, hier ist etwas passiert. Sie können den Ort relativ schnell und genau lokalisieren und auch die Tiefe und die Stärke, die Magnitude des Bebens. Das läuft als erstes ein. Dann kommen die Unterwasserdrucksensoren, von denen immer nur gesprochen wird, wenn wir über Tsunamiwarnsystem reden, die feststellen, aha, da ist eine starke Druckänderung im Wasser, in der Tiefe. Dann haben wir Oberflächen, Bojen, die eben registrieren, wenn der gesamte Wasserspiegel plötzlich absackt und wieder ansteigt. Dann haben wir an der Küste...
Also sozusagen so eine Tsunami-Schockwelle quasi konkret messen kann.
Und dann kommt als nächste Informationsquelle die Pegelstandsmesser an den Küsten selber, also diese Stangen, die man immer sieht, mit diesen rot-weißen Markierungen, die eben sagen, ah das Wasser fällt ab und steigt jetzt wieder. Dann haben wir weitere Informationen aus GPS-Messungen, aus dem All. Und all das wird zusammengeführt in den entsprechenden Informationssystem. Und der Trick bei dem Ganzen, um die Reaktionszeit noch zu verkürzen, ist das, was ich vorhin schon mal kurz erwähnt hatte, dass man nämlich Vorsorge betreibt. Dass man schon mal vorab ausrechnet, was würde passieren, wenn an der Stelle ein Beben der Stärke x ausgelöst werden würde. Welche Welle würde entstehen und wo würde die hinlaufen? Welche Regionen wären betroffen? Welche Bevölkerungsdichte ist da momentan angesiedelt? Wie wäre die Warnung auszusprechen? All das wird vorab schon mal gerechnet und wird als Modell in dieses Steuerungssystem eingebaut. Und wenn jetzt die erste Information von den Seismischenmessungen kommt, dann wird sofort abgeglichen mit allem, was gespeichert ist, welches Szenario ist denn wohl das Wahrscheinlichste oder welche. Und das wird immer bei jeder neu eintreffenden Information abgedatet, sodass man zu einem immer wahrscheinlicheren Endszenario kommt und dann zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt, der entscheidende Officer im Katastrophenzentrum sagen kann, evakuieren ja oder nein.
Verstehe. Das heißt, ich nehme an, so eine Berechnung ließe sich in Echtzeit überhaupt gar nicht mehr durchführen, weil einfach viel zu viele Daten dort involviert werden. Das heißt, man rechnet das alles vor und hat solche Ereignistabellen, an denen man anhand der tatsächlich auftreffenden Sensorinformation vergleichen kann, was davon ist jetzt das Wahrscheinlichste und hier hat es jetzt einfach eine gewisse Wahrscheinlichkeit überschritten, dass man sagen kann, es ist mit der und der Wahrscheinlichkeit zu rechnen, dass es eine starke Flutwelle geben wird in diesem Bereich. Und, okay, aber da ist ja jetzt sozusagen, die Satelliten spielen jetzt noch gar keine Rolle dabei, oder?
Ja, die Satelliten spielen durch die Messung aus GPS, wo ich die Meeresoberfläche mit ausmessen kann, natürlich schon eine Rolle. Aber der Clou war wirklich das Informationssystem, was man dort entwickelt hat.
Okay, aber ich hatte ja gefragt, wie diese, aber was heißt GPS-Messung? Also was genau wird da gemessen?
Es wird von den Bojen, die an der Erdoberfläche sind, werden Signale zu Satelliten aufgeschickt und es wird direkt die Position der Bojen über der Meeresoberfläche dann über diese GPS registriert.
Also sind diese Bojen verteut oder schwimmen die frei rum? Wie muss man das jetzt vorstellen?
Die sind verteut und es gibt auch welche, die sind unten angesiedelt am Meeresboot und steigen dann hoch und senden dann.
Wenn was ist. Ach so, dann lösen die sich sozusagen. Okay, jetzt muss ich mal kurz weg zum Senden. Ich bin dann mal kurz. Okay, gut, das heißt, da ist dann die konkrete Kommunikation. Einerseits mit den Satelliten zur Rückmeldung. Also ein Kommunikationsnetzwerk, was an der Stelle genutzt wird. Aber eben auch die konkrete Positionsbestimmung spielt da eine Rolle. Das heißt, man sieht sozusagen, wenn so eine Welle quasi eine Boje wegdrückt. Kann man das sagen? Also ist ein Strömungsmesser an der Stelle eigentlich mehr.
Ja, und das zweite, wo die Satelliteninformation mit reinspielt, ist natürlich die Kaptierung der betroffenen Gebiete, der potentiell betroffenen Gebiete, dass ich da schon auch ausrechnen kann anhand der dreidimensionalen Geländeform, was denn eine Welle bedecken würde, wenn sie in einer bestimmten Höhe über dieses Gebiet rüberfließt. Also wirklich die echt gefährdeten Gebiete ausweisen kann und kartieren kann und sagen, da muss unbedingt evakuiert werden.
Was man jetzt bei diesen ganzen Schilderungen ja immer wieder heraus hört, ist einerseits ist es natürlich eine Tätigkeit mit Muße. Man schaut sich über einen längeren Zeitraum Regionen an, gewinnt viele Daten und hat einen riesigen Datenpool und dann wahrscheinlich auch erstmal das Problem, diese Daten effektiv auswerten zu können. Andererseits gibt es aber Fälle, wie zum Beispiel jetzt hier, wo man eben schnell reagieren muss bzw. was dann auch so die eigentliche Steuerung der Satelliten betrifft, wo ein extremes Timing auch gefragt ist. Anfangs hatten wir ja kurz den Fall, dass Satelliten geostationär aufgestellt werden, großen Abständen, aber von daher nicht nahe schauen können. Auf der anderen Seite haben wir auch von Satelliten gesprochen, die 50 cm Pixelauflösung schaffen. Wo befinden die sich denn? Und was nehmen die für einen Weg um die Erde?
Die geostationären Satelliten, von denen wir am Anfang geredet haben, die also in 36.000 km Entfernung stehen, die erfassen die Erde als Ganzes. Das heißt, man sieht wirklich die Halbkugel. Und wenn ich jetzt höhere Genauigkeiten als diese 500-Meter-Pixel haben möchte, muss ich dichter rangehen. Und wenn ich dichter rangehe, wird natürlich mein Aufnahmegebiet kleiner werden. Und die Geschwindigkeit des Satelliten, mit der er in seiner Bahn stabil ist, die ist natürlich auch eine andere. Und die typischen Erdbeobachtungs-Satelliten, die fliegen halt in Bahnen zwischen 500 und 900 km. Und je nachdem, welche Aufnahmesysteme sie an Bord haben, nehmen sie dann Streifen auf, wenn sie über die Erdoberfläche hinwegkreisen, die zwischen 2000 km und auch nur 10 km breit sind. Und das Problem, was ich habe bei der ganzen Konstellation, ist, die Daten müssen ja runterkommen zu den Bodenstationen. Weil an Bord speichern geht nur in ganz beschränkter Datenmenge. Ich glaube, die neueren Satelliten haben meist so 250 GB, die sie speichern können. Ansonsten müssen sie über eine Bodenstation drüberkommen, wo sie ihre Daten loswerden. Und auch da gibt es wieder Beschränkungen durch die Bandbreite des Übertragungskanals. Das passiert meistens im X-Band, also etwa 10 Gigahertz. Und da hat man eine beschränkte Übertragungsbreite. Das heißt, ich kann jetzt auch nicht mit einem höchst auflösenden 1-Meter-Satelliten einen Streifen aufnehmen, der 100 Kilometer breit ist, weil ich die Daten gar nicht mehr runter bekomme in einem kurzen Zeitraum. Und ein Satellit braucht, wenn er in diesen Höhen fliegt, etwa eine 1,5 Stunden, bis er einmal um die Erde rum ist. Das heißt, wenn er hier in Oberpfaffenhofen am Horizont auftaucht, dann ist er in 20 Minuten wieder verschwunden auf der anderen Seite. Und wenn er hier oben im Norden auftaucht, dann nimmt er vielleicht gerade Spitzbergen auf. Und wenn er im Süden verschwindet, dann ist er im oberen Bereich der Sahelzone. Das heißt, nur das können wir auch sehen, wenn wir hier aufnehmen. Man kann grundsätzlich sagen, wenn ein Satellit einen großen Streifen aufnehmen soll, z.B. ganz Europa in einem Überflug erfassen soll, dann wird die Auflösung vielleicht so bei 200 Meternpixeln liegen. Und wenn ich auf einen Meternpixel runter gehe, dann habe ich Größenordnung 10-15 km breite Streifen. Jetzt kann man sich natürlich ausrechnen, wie lange braucht so ein höchst auflösender Satellit, um die ganze Erde einmal in dieser 1-Meter-Qualität zu erfassen. Bei 32.000 Kilometer Umfang kann das schon sehr, sehr lange dauern, wenn ich 10 km Streifen habe.
Wie lange brauchen so die Satelliten üblicherweise, um einmal rumzukommen?
Eine Umdrehung, 1,5 Stunden, die sind 90 Minuten. Dann muss man natürlich noch berücksichtigen, dass das eine Wolkenbedeckung ist. Bis man eine wolkenfreie Abdeckung der ganzen Erde hat, das kann sehr, sehr lange dauern. Ich kann mich erinnern, wir haben 1989-90 den ersten Satellitenbild Atlas Deutschland gemacht, mit Landsat-Garten. Der hatte noch breite Streifen, die waren etwa 170 Kilometer breit. Bild Atlas, ja. Dort haben wir zwei Jahre lang Daten sammeln müssen, bis wir Deutschland mal wirklich wolkenfrei zusammen hatten.
Zwei Jahre lang?
Zwei Jahre Daten haben wir zusammen suchen müssen. Weil es immer irgendwo Wolken gab. Wir sind ja hier noch in gemäßigter Zone, in Tropen hat man da fast überhaupt keine Chance, das hinzubekommen. Und man muss auch sagen, ich hatte vorhin mal kurz gesagt, dass inzwischen auch sehr viele private Firmen diese Satelliten betreiben. Wenn man solche großen Kartenprojekte machen will, dann kostet das viel Geld. Weil die natürlich die Daten nicht dafür umsonst zur Verfügung stellen. Und so ein, um mal eine Größenordnung zu nennen, ein Bild, 15 mal 15 Kilometer, in dieser Bestauflösung kostet halt 2000 Euro. Sie können sich vorstellen, was Google Earth bezahlt haben muss für die höchst auflösende Abdeckung der ganzen Erden.
Das war bestimmt nicht billig.
Nein, sicher nicht. Na gut, die haben wahrscheinlich den Großkundenpreis bekommen.
Ja, die kaufen auch von jedem. Gibt es denn freies Kartenmaterial, was man nicht kaufen muss, was irgendwas taugt? Wird das auch im Rahmen der Forschungstätigkeit sozusagen auch frei zur Verfügung gestellt? Oder werden diese Daten auch zu einem Preis angeboten?
Das Problem ist, wenn die Daten kaufen, bei den Firmen oder auch bei anderen Anbietern, erwerben sie nie das Eigentumsrecht. Man erwirbt immer nur ein Nutzungsrecht. Und das Nutzungsrecht ist meist in einem Vertrag, diese End-User-License-Agreement, festgelegt. Da steht genau drin, was sie mit den Daten machen dürfen, was sie nicht machen dürfen. Und das ist immer so ein bisschen ein grau Bereich, wie sich solche Rechte an Daten verändern, wenn ich dort etwas an Auswertung gemacht habe. Also zum Beispiel aus einem Rohdatensatz dann ein bestimmtes Produkt erzeugt habe. Ab wo habe ich sozusagen ein Intellectual Property Right erworben, also eine eigene schöpferische Leistung in die Daten hineingesteckt, sodass sich das Eigentumsrecht an den Daten ändert. Das muss man wirklich juristisch im Einzelfall dann abklären. Ab wann die Daten dann einem selber gehören und man damit machen kann, was man will oder ab wann man diese ursprünglichen Datenrechte beachten muss.
Aber was ist mit den Satelliten, die jetzt vom DLR betrieben werden?
Wir selber betreiben ja gar nicht so sehr viele Satelliten. Das meiste, was wir verwenden, ist entweder frei von Haus aus. Also zum Beispiel alle diese Daten von Satelliten im Auflösungsbereich um 200 Meter. Ich nenne mal ein paar Namen. Das ist Modis, ein amerikanisches System. Die Daten kriegen sie frei. Das sind Dinge, die sind wirklich für die Öffentlichkeit bestimmt. Meteosat kriegen sie ja auch einen bestimmten Bereich von Daten. Kostenfrei. Es gibt auch viele Schulen, die empfangen diese Daten selber. Sie müssen nur dieses Empfangsequipment haben. Dann gibt es den grundsätzlich kostenpflichtigen Bereich, dieser höchstauflösenden Daten. Also alles, was unterhalb von 50 Metern kostet, kostet Geld.
Aber so Meteosat kann man sich selber empfangen?
Da gibt es einen Bereich von Daten, den sie frei verfügbar machen. Den kann man selbst empfangen. Das Empfangsequipment ist auch gar nicht teuer. Ich glaube, für 2000 Euro kriegt man dann eine komplette Anlage, mit der man das empfangen kann.
Dann kriegt man es quasi direkt vom Satelliten?
Dann hat man es direkt vom Satelliten.
Und in dem Falle von Modis?
Bei Modis ist die Empfangsantenne ein bisschen komplexer, aber auch die Daten sind dann frei.
Das heißt, bei den anderen kommen die dann schon verschlüsselt runter?
Das ist verschlüsseln, da muss man halt wie bei Fernsehsignalen auch entsprechende Lizenz kaufen, dass man die Daten empfangen darf. Und wir empfangen zum Beispiel hier in Kooperation mit einer kommerziellen Firma European Space Imaging-Daten von zwei sehr hochauflösenden Satelliten, WorldU2 und ICONOS. Und das ist eben eine Kooperation. Wir empfangen und speichern die Daten und die Firma verkauft diese Daten. Dann bezahlt uns eben entsprechend für die Service, den wir da leisten.
Aber wenn wir jetzt diese Modis-Daten, ich meine Meteorosat-Daten, die muss man sich aber jetzt nicht selber empfangen, um sie zu bekommen. Die kann man sich auch irgendwo im Netz holen?
Es gibt viele Daten, die man im Netz direkt runterladen kann. Also gerade Meteorosat hat einen Service Meteorcast. Da kann man das bekommen, ohne dass man Antennenanlagen da betreiben muss. Und gerade die amerikanische Wetterbehörde NOAA, die hat ein sehr großes Angebot an kostenfreien Daten im Web. Es gibt noch ein paar andere, ganz gute Adressen, wo man Daten, der Global Land Cover Facility GSFC, der University of Maryland, die haben ein sehr umfangreiches Programm an kostenfreien Daten, den man sich herunterladen kann.
Also falls man sich sein eigenes Google Earth bauen möchte, könnte man das zum Beispiel verwenden. Was mich nochmal interessieren würde ist, wie kommt es zu diesen Projekten? Was jetzt ja klar geworden ist, denke ich Erdbeobachtungen, die Einsatzmöglichkeiten sind nahezu unbegrenzt. Man muss eigentlich nur mit irgendeinem neuen Interesse aufwarten und schon kann man sich vorstellen, wie man das Ganze von oben begleiten könnte. Die Beispiele waren ja nun zahlreich. Im Wetterbereich ist alles selbstverständlich. Im Umweltbereich bietet sich viel an, aber eben auch Exploitation, also Gewinnung von Bodenschätzen etc. all diese ganzen Sachen. Wer kommt jetzt auf wen zu? Wird das meiste eigentlich durch private Firmen abgedeckt, die da sozusagen einen Markt sehen und ihre eigenen Satelliten entwickeln und in die Luft schicken? Was ist eigentliche Forschung? Wo gibt es öffentliche Programme, aus denen solche Projekte entstehen? Inwiefern ist zum Beispiel da auch DR und ESA mit privaten Projekten verbunden? Wie funktioniert das Ganze? Wie kommt man da zu seinen Projekten, zu seinen Aufträgen? Wie ist das miteinander vernetzt?
Es ist so, dass man auf der einen Seite natürlich bei vielen Staaten so etwas hat, wie sie wollen, Basiskartierung machen. Nehmen wir an, ein sehr großes, ein flächenmäßig großes Land, das verkehrsmäßig nicht gut erschlossen ist, möchte eine Basiskartierung haben unter Verwendung von Satellitenbildern. Die werden dann natürlich von sich aus aktiv werden und werden entweder selbst ein Satellitenprogramm aufsetzen oder werden das kaufen, die Daten einkaufen. Dann gibt es aber auch internationale Forschungsvorhaben, die herausfinden wollen, was kann man mit den Daten machen, um neue Anwendungsfelder zu erschließen. Und es gibt ganz große internationale Programme, an deren Ende Services stehen sollen, die jeder Bürger in Anspruch nehmen kann. Und das momentan größte Programm in Europa in dieser Art ist das Global Monitoring Environmental Security Program, das GMES. Das ist gemeinsam aufgelegt worden von der EU und der ESA und hat zum Ziel, dass Services entwickelt werden, in denen alle diese Daten plus Daten, die am Boden erhoben werden, statistische Daten, die in den Ländern bereits vorhanden sind, Daten von Services, die bereits existieren, dort mit integriert werden können. Und die Arbeitsteilung in diesem Programm sieht eben so aus, dass es die ESA als Weltraumorganisation in Europa den Teil übernommen hat, der die Satellitenprogramme selber steuert und initiiert. Das heißt, dort wird es ein Satellitenprogramm für die nächsten Jahrzehnte geben, das nennt sich Sentinel. Und dort werden verschiedene Satelliten fliegen, die sich mit atmosphärischer Sensorik beschäftigen, mit klimarelevanten Dingen, aber auch mit der Landoberfläche oder der Erkundung der Meeressoberfläche und der Gewässer. Und die EU selber hat sich eher konzentriert auf die Nutzung dieser Daten, indem sie zum einen wissenschaftliche Programme aufgelegt hat im Forschungsrahmenprogramm, die sich mit neuen Techniken, neuen Auswerteverfahren befassen und zum anderen eben die bereits erwähnten Services, die eingerichtet werden sollen in Europa. Und da reicht eben auch der Anwendungsbereich der Services von Landanwendungen über Gewässeranwendungen bis hin zu ziviler Sicherheit und Katastrophenhilfe.
Was sind denn so die aktuell betriebenen Projekte im Erderkundungsbereich, die jetzt satellitengeschützt im wesentlichen Welle machen? Also vor kurzem ist ja zweite CRIOSAT gestartet zum Beispiel. Das ist ja auch klassische Erderkundung.
Das ist klassische Erderkundung, auch gerade im Bereich wissenschaftlicher Erkenntnis. Das sind eben Satelliten, die sich mit der Erde selber befassen, mit der festen Erde oder auch Satelliten, die sich mit dem Erdmagnetfeld befassen, wie der GRACE. Es gibt aber darüber hinaus auch Satelliten, die eben einen sehr großen Anwendungsbereich haben, wie zum Beispiel diese ganze Serie von Radarsatelliten, in denen Deutschland ja eine führende Rolle einnimmt. Das Ganze hat angefangen mit einer Kartierung der Erde, die mit einem Instrument, das an Bord des Space Shuttle geflogen ist, im Jahr 2000, das war das SRTM, das Shuttle Radar Topography Mission, wo zum ersten Mal versucht wurde, ein digitales Höhenmodell der Erde zu bekommen. Und die Erfahrung, die man da gewonnen hat, die ist dann eingeflossen in den bereits erwähnten Satelliten TerraSAR, der 2007 gestartet worden ist. Und das ist ein Satellit der allerneuesten Bauart und Technik, der seitdem hervorragende Bilder liefert, Radarbilder mit 1 m Auflösung im sogenannten X-Band, also mit 3 cm Wellenlänge. Und dieser Satellit ist jetzt gerade vor Wochen ergänzt worden durch einen zweiten Zwillingssatelliten, den Tandem X. Das ist so ein kleines Wortspiel. Also dieses DEM steht immer für Digital Elevation Model, also digitales Geländemodell. Und das Tandem soll andeuten, dass hier zwei Satelliten im Formationsflug zusammenfliegen und Daten erheben. Und das technische Neuland, das man hier betreten hat, ist, dass diese Satelliten inzwischen im Abstand von 200 Metern hintereinander herfliegen, in 514 Kilometer Höhe.
200 Meter?
200 Meter.
Das ist ja bei den Geschwindigkeiten so, als würde ich auf der Autobahn jemandem 10 Zentimeter Abstand folgen.
Richtig. Wobei sie natürlich keinen Verkehr zu beachten haben. Aber diese Bahn ist jetzt noch komplizierter, weil sie helixförmig ineinander verwirbelt ist. Und diese beiden Satelliten sollen...
Das heißt, die rotieren umeinander herum?
Rotieren umeinander herum, ja. Warum? Das hat damit zu tun, dass man bestimmte Aufnahmekonfigurationen haben möchte und dass man Kollisionen auch vermeiden möchte. Und einer von den Satelliten sendet und an beide Satelliten empfängt. Und mit Hilfe dieser neuen Technik, die sich Radar Interferometrie nennt, kann man eben sehr, sehr genaue Höhenmodelle der Erde erzeugen. Ich will es mal ganz kurz vielleicht erläutern. Ein Radarsignal wird vom Satelliten ausgesendet, trifft auf den Boden auf und wird wieder zurückreflektiert. Aus der reinen Laufzeit kann ich schon mal ganz grob die Entfernung des Punktes vom Satelliten ausrechnen, der getroffen worden ist auf der Erdoberfläche. Wenn ich jetzt eine zweite Antenne habe...
Und die Auflösung ist, was war das, ein Meter?
Die Auflösung bei diesem einfachen System ist nicht ein Meter, sondern diese genauere Auflösung kommt erst dadurch, dass ich einen zweiten Empfänger habe, der räumlich vom ersten Empfänger entfernt ist. Das hat man damals bei der Shuttle-Mission gemacht, in dem man ein Empfängergerät an Bord des Shuttle hatte und ein zweites an einem 60 Meter langen Arm, den man ausgefahren hat. Und dann hat man sozusagen so etwas wie eine Stereo-Bandbreite und kann mit zwei Empfangsgeräten das Signal empfangen. Und da diese Radarsignale kohärent sind, also wirklich phasengleich von all diesen kleinen Elementarantennen ausgesandt werden, kann ich jetzt auch noch die Phasendifferenz, also nicht nur die reine Laufzeitdifferenz, sondern auch die Phasendifferenz der Radarwelle, wenn sie zurückkommt, an beiden Instrumenten hernehmen, um dann Interferometrie zu betreiben. Und mit dieser Technik und dieser neuen Konfiguration, 200 Meter Abstand dieser beiden Satelliten, da komme ich dann in Auflösungen, die sind schon extrem. Das geht also wirklich bis zwei Meter Höhenauflösung. Und man erhofft sich eben in drei Jahren gemeinsame Missionen dieser beiden Satelliten, die Erde einmal komplett erfassen zu können. Und dann hätte man ein wunderschönes, einheitliches, standardisiertes Höhenmodell der ganzen Erde mit dieser Genauigkeit.
Das heißt, ein Höhenmodell durch Radarmessungen wurde überhaupt erst vor zehn Jahren mit dieser Shuttle-Mission das erste Mal wirklich in Angriff genommen?
Das war die erste Mission, die es wirklich global versucht hat. Es gab neben dem deutschen Instrument, das da an Bord war, auch so ein X-Band-Radar, ein amerikanisches Instrument. Das nannte sich Sir C, also Shuttle Imaging Radar. Und das C stand für ein anderes Spektralband im Radar. Und da wurden zum ersten Mal globale Höhenmodelle gemessen. Die Amerikaner haben die Erde zwischen, ich glaube, plus, minus 60 Grad, weil der Shuttle ja nicht diese polaren Bahnen fliegt, sondern äquatoriale Bahnen, zwischen plus und 60 Grad Breite haben die Amerikaner komplett aufnehmen können, weil ihre Aufnahme streifenbreiter waren. Die Mission hatte nur 14 Tage gedauert. Und das deutsche Instrument hat zwar eine höhere Auflösung gehabt, hat dafür aber schmalere Streifen aufnehmen müssen. Und da waren immer so rautenförmige Stücke, wo keine Aufnahme erfolgt ist. Und deswegen hat man dann gesagt, dann machen wir das Ganze vom Satelliten. Und da sind wir nicht beschränkt in der Missionsdauer. Und so ist es praktisch.
Wie hoch fliegen denn diese Tandem?
Die fliegen beide in 514 Kilometern Höhe.
514. Und seit wann sind die alle beide oben?
Der Start ist im Juli erfolgt von dem Tandemgerät. Also das Terrasse flog ja schon seit 2007. Jetzt Juli 2010. Am Anfang einer solchen Mission steht ja immer, dass zunächst einmal alle Komponenten an Bord ausgetestet werden. Und dann versuchte man sich von der ursprünglich sehr viel größeren Entfernung der beiden Satelliten hier im Kontrollzentrum, die immer dichter zusammen zu bringen und diese endgültige Schlusskonfiguration von 200 Meter Abstand zu erreichen. Und das ist eben gerade letzte Woche geglückt. Wenn Sie in die Presse geschaut haben, war jetzt in den großen Medien überall die Erfolgsmeldung, dass man jetzt diese 200 Meter erreicht hat und auch schon die ersten Bilder aus dieser neuen Konstellation dann gerechnet hat. Und die sind, so wie es bisher aussieht, ganz hervorragend.
Um nochmal zu verstehen, was diese beiden Satelliten tun. Also, die fliegen nebeneinander her. Dieser Abstand ist auch konstant. Sie sind immer 200 Meter voneinander entfernt. Und jetzt fliegen sie beide über den Polar, die Polar-Route sozusagen, also Nordpol, Südpol, um die Erde herum. Rotieren dabei aber wahrscheinlich in Scheibchen immer weiter von links nach rechts oder von Ost nach West. Wie muss man sich das vorstellen?
Man muss zunächst mal sagen, aufgrund des sehr hohen Energiebedarfs einer solchen Radarantenne können die ohnehin nicht die ganze Zeit aufnehmen. Das heißt, die Aufnahmedauer, die pro Orbit besteht, liegt bei drei Minuten, wenn ich es richtig in Erinnerung habe. Das heißt, da ist schon eine Beschränkung, dass sie nicht permanent aufnehmen. Das ist im Übrigen bei fast allen hochauflösenden kommerziellen Satelliten genau das Gleiche. Dort wird nur auf Bestellung aufgenommen. Die nehmen gar nicht permanent auf. Und bei diesen Radarsatelliten ist halt der Energiebedarf das einschränkende Kriterium.
Aber es soll doch letzten Endes flächendeckend erfasst werden. Dann könnte man ja eigentlich auch die ganze Zeit...
Ja, es wird halt gezielt in Aufnahmeplan erstellt. Das Schöne bei Radar ist ja, man ist jetzt nicht mehr abhängig von Wolken und Nacht. Man kann also wirklich Tag und Nacht arbeiten und hat dann so ein Schedule, nachdem das Ganze abgearbeitet wird.
Aber was hält jetzt den Satelliten davon ab, einfach die ganze Zeit, während er fliegt, zu generieren?
Weil er keinen Strom bekommt.
Ach so, weil er sich sozusagen aufladen muss über Solarpanele.
Diese Radantennen müssen ja doch eine gewisse Leistung erbringen.
Also pro Orbit, also auch hier ist er eine 1,5 Stunden sozusagen einmal drumherum unterwegs. Das heißt, man hat dann pro Tag maximal eine halbe Stunde, die man überhaupt aufnehmen kann, ungefähr. Richtig gerechnet.
Könnte hinkommen, ja.
Nur um sich das mal so vorzustellen. Aber dabei wird halt permanent sozusagen von Pol zu Pol geflogen und die beiden Satelliten drehen sich jetzt die ganze Zeit um sich herum.
Das ist schon ausgeklügelt, wie sie sich drehen. Sodass sie wirklich bei diesen Aufnahmen machen, dann auch wirklich in der festgelegten Geometrie zusammenwerfen.
Sie spinnen sozusagen in ihrer Laufbahn so eine Doppelhelix um die Erde herum. Also das ist ja sozusagen ein totales Novum. Das hat es jetzt so in der Form noch gar nicht gegeben, dass man wirklich zwei Satelliten hat, die quasi wie ein Satellit daherkommen, weil sie sozusagen zusammenarbeiten, um etwas zu erzielen. Oder gab es das schon mal in irgendeiner Form?
Nein, das gab es noch nicht. Man denkt auch an ganze Schwärme von Satelliten, von denen einer sendet und viele andere nur empfangen. Das wird also ein zukünftiges Konzept sein, ist auch billiger. Man muss auch mal sagen, es gab so eine Entwicklung in den vergangenen Jahrzehnten zu immer größeren Satelliten. Da war die Grundidee die, gerade bei Atmosphärenmessung, dass man zum gleichen Zeitpunkt alle Parameter gleichzeitig messen wollte. Da hat man also eine Plattform geschaffen. Auf diese Plattform hat man sehr viele Einzelsensoren draufgepackt, hat dann einen komplexen Aufnahmezeitsplan entwickelt, wann, wer, wie, wo aufnimmt. Und hat das Ganze dann ins All gebracht. Und der letzte Dinosaurier dieser Art war der Envisat. Das Problem dabei ist, dass man erstens natürlich eine sehr hohe Stromversorgung benötigt für die vielen Instrumente und dass die Instrumente eben sich gegenseitig stören können. Und der zweite Nachteil ist, das Ganze ist so teuer, dass man kein Backup-Modell hat. Das heißt, der Satellit muss so raufkommen, wie er ist. Und wenn er ins Wasser fällt, dann ist alles umsonst gewesen und man hat keinen Ersatz. Inzwischen geht die Tendenz eher zu kleinen Satelliten. Und man kann dann auch unterschiedlich viele Kooperationspartner auswählen. Das reicht vom russischen Militär bis hin zu den großen Ajanespace oder den Amerikanern oder den Russen oder Chinesen, um den Satelliten ins All zu bringen. Und soweit ich mich erinnere, haben die Russen sogar ihre SS-20 damit entsorgt, die sie laut Abrüstungsvertrag hätten verschrotten müssen, indem sie halt zivile Erdbeobachtungssatelliten ins All geschossen haben damit. Das ist also ein kostengünstigeres Prinzip. Man kann von den kleinen Satelliten gleich mehrere bauen, sodass wenn der eine dann eben nicht in den Orbit kommt, in den er sollte, dann hat man eben noch einen zweiten in Reserve.
Und die nächste Stufe ist sozusagen, dass man jetzt nicht nur Reserve hat, sondern dass man eben sozusagen diese Gleichzeitigkeit auch über mehrere Satelliten wiederum stellen kann, indem man sich dann einfach synchronisiert. Wie muss man sich das dann vorstellen, dass dann irgendwann 20, 30 kleine Mini-Satellitchen mit einer Ladung nach oben geschickt werden, die dann da so Weihnachtsklitter sozusagen in den Orbit bringen? Das muss ja auch ganz interessant aussehen, wenn man sich das von unten anschaut.
Ja, wenn die in Höhen fliegen, in denen sie von der Sonne beleuchtet werden, wird das sicherlich zu sehen sein von unten.
Die Weihnachtsdeko ist dann sozusagen noch kostenlos dazu. Ja, ich hab's vorhin kurz erwähnt, auch ein aktuelles Projekt ist der KryoSat. Was soll denn der rausfinden?
Der ist hauptsächlich entwickelt worden, um die Eisbedeckung der Erde zu messen, weil natürlich die Eisbedeckung direkt abhängt von der Temperatur der Erde. Und alle Klimaabschätzungen, die im Rahmen des globalen Wandels vorgenommen werden, haben natürlich die Eisbedeckung der Erde als einen ganz wesentlichen Faktor. Und der KryoSat ist eben der Satellit, der speziell dafür gebaut und ausgewählt wurde und der jetzt hoffentlich die entsprechende Daten in der Genauigkeit auch liefern wird. Man hat vorher die Eisbedeckung ja schon mit verschiedenen Systemen gemessen, die aber eben von ihrer Instrumentauslegung eigentlich nicht direkt dafür gebaut worden sind. Das waren eben die ganz normalen Wetter-Satelliten, beziehungsweise diese bereits erwähnten in der Klasse dieser MODIS oder NOAA, also Wetter- und Klimaforschung, Auflösung 200 bis 500 Meter oder ein Kilometer. Die Daten kriegt man dann aber eben auch mehrfach am Tag. Das ist eben der Vorteil. Da ist überhaupt, ich hatte vorhin diese Wiederholrate schon erwähnt gehabt, die geostationären Satelliten, die liefern ja zum Teil Daten alle 15 Minuten, während manche hochauflösende Satelliten dann wirklich nur alle Woche ein Bild der gleichen Region liefern können. Früher konnte man Satelliten auch nicht vom Boden aus steuern, dass sie zur Seite hinschauen, sondern die haben eben wirklich nur senkrecht nach unten in Nadir-Richtung geschaut. Inzwischen sind die meisten per Telekommando verschwenkbar. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel ein Bild eines bestimmten Objektes oder einer Region haben möchte, dann kann ich das ordnen. Und dann wird entsprechend der Satellit verschwenkt und schaut dann zur Seite runter und nimmt das Gebiet auf, wenn er nicht direkt jetzt in nächster Zeit drüber käme. Muss man natürlich zahlen dafür. Das ist klar, aber man kommt eben jetzt von diesen mehrwöchigen Wiederholraten auf nur wenige Tage, was natürlich ein großer Vorteil da ist.
Und bringt das nicht so Verzerrung mit sich, wenn man so schräg schaut?
Es verschlechtert sich auf jeden Fall die räumliche Auflösung, das ist ja klar. Ansonsten gibt es natürlich Rechenprogramme, die diese Dinge korrigieren können dann.
Welche anderen Systeme sind denn noch derzeit im Einsatz, die so zu diesem gesamten Erkenntnisreichtum beitragen?
Man hat die bereits erwähnten Wetter-Satelliten. Die sind auch schon seit Jahrzehnten zu einem System zusammengeschaltet, sodass man also nicht nur den Meteosat hat, der halt unseren europäischen Bereich in der Mitte hat, sondern da gibt es eben amerikanisches, russisches, chinesisches, indisches System, sodass man jederzeit rund um die Erde eigentlich die globale Erfassung hat. Dann haben wir im Bereich dieser mittelauflösenden, also 500 Meter runter bis 100 Meter etwa, eine ganze Reihe Satelliten, die oft auch von den Wetter-Services der einzelnen Nationen betrieben werden, wo die Daten auch noch auf kostenfrei empfangen werden können. Dann gibt es den Bereich der hochauflösenden optischen Satelliten, bis Pixelgrößen bis ein Meter runter. Das ist dieser rein kommerziell betriebene Anwendungsbereich. Dann haben wir die großen Radarsatelliten-Programme, wo gerade Europa und insbesondere Deutschland sehr stark ist, auch Kanada. Und wir haben, was demnächst kommen wird, jetzt Satelliten, die Hyperspektral aufnehmen, wo wir dann eben 200 Spektalkanäle und mehr bekommen, die eben ganz schmalbandige Aufnahmen liefern werden. So etwas gibt es bereits im Bereich der Atmosphärensensorik. Die Atmosphärensensorik schaut ja jetzt nicht direkt auf die Erde runter, sondern die haben Sensoren, die eben auch schräg durch die Atmosphäre Profile messen. Und da ist man natürlich ganz speziell interessiert an Absorption ganz bestimmter Spurengase in der Atmosphäre, sodass man hier eben auch diese ganz engbandigen Aufnahmekanäle benötigt. Die sind aber oft dann wirklich zugeschnitten auf ganz bestimmte Spurengase, von denen man weiß, die absorbieren halt genau in dem Bereich.
Dieses, wie hochauflösend kann man denn eigentlich auf den Planeten blicken, das ist ja immer wieder so die klassische Frage. Gerade so dieses, wer beobachtet uns alle? Und könnte ich schon mal eine Zeitung mitlesen, wenn sie von oben schauen? Was, welche Bedeutung? Ich meine, das Ganze hat ja auch eine militärische Bedeutung schon immer gehabt, von oben schauen zu können. Und es wird sicherlich auch viel geschaut. Die militärischen Projekte unterliegen natürlich einer bestimmten Geheimhaltung. Aber was weiß man denn sozusagen darüber, was in dem Bereich auch getan wird? Was ist vor allem auch die Technik derzeit wahrscheinlich zu leisten in der Lage?
Zum einen im zivilen Bereich kann man sagen, liegt die momentane Grenze der Auflösung, die tatsächlich verwirklich ist, bei 50 Centimeterpixeln. Das wird sich vielleicht ein bisschen noch höher treiben lassen, aber irgendwann spielt einfach der atmosphärische Einfluss da eine Rolle, dass es nicht mehr besser geht. Aus diesen Orbitbahnen 500 bis 900 Kilometern. Es gibt militärische Satelliten, insbesondere die der Keyhole, also KH heißen die immer irgendeine Nummer dahinter, wo man die technischen Spezifikationen nicht genau kennt. Die haben zum Teil auch ein bisschen andere Bahnen. Die fliegen dann eher elliptische Bahnen. Da muss man grundsätzlich sagen, die Militärs sind gar nicht so sehr an flächenhafter Fassung größerer Gebiete interessiert. Das können sie ja kaufen. Das gibt es ja auf einem normalen kommerziellen Markt, in guter Qualität zu kaufen. Warum sollten sie selber da Satelliten haben? Sondern die interessieren ja Punktziele. Die haben ganz bestimmte Gebiete, wo sie sehr genaue Informationen haben möchten. Und diese Bilder, wo man Nummernschilder lesen kann oder die IS West ja von der Pravda unterscheiden kann, das sind sicherlich keine Aufnahmen von Satelliten, sondern aus irgendwelchen hochfliegenden Spionageflugzeugen, die eben 10 Kilometer Höhe oder 15 Kilometer Höhe fliegen.
Also Drohnen.
Ja, also das ist mit Sicherheit nicht vom Satelliten. Und ich denke auch, ein großes Interessegebiet der Militärs ist eher die Funküberwachung. Denn da hat man Echtzeitinformation. Bei allen Satellitendaten ist ja immer das Problem, wie lange es dauert, von der Aufnahme bis zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo ich das Bild wirklich auf meinem Rechner zur Verfügung habe. Und das geht halt vom Satelliten aus nicht so schnell zu machen. Da werden sie Flugzeuge verwenden, wo sie direkt senden können.
Die Drohnenentwicklung, die geht ja ganz hurtig voran derzeit. Das merkt man natürlich auch im militärischen Bereich. Aber ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass das jetzt für die Erdbeobachtung auch kein uninteressantes Trägersystem ist, oder?
Es werden auch Versuche gemacht mit unbemannten Flugzeugen und anderen Flugkörpern. Das reicht also vom Zeppelin aus bis hin zu solchen kleinen oder unbemannten solarbetriebenen Flugzeugen, die in bestimmten Höhe kreisen. Die typische zivile Anwendung wäre Eventüberwachung, also Großveranstaltungen, die man überwachen möchte, oder Verkehrsüberwachung. Man macht momentan Versuche noch mit Flugzeugen, indem man solche Systeme einsetzt, um auch Geschwindigkeiten von Fahrzeugen erfassen zu können, Stau, Meldungen über größere Gebiete hinweg aussprechen zu können. Und da denkt man eben auch an sehr hochfliegende, solarbetriebene Träger, die eben solche Instrumente an Bord haben und die permanent nur ein bestimmtes Gebiet umkreisen und dort immer ständig aufnehmen.
Da ließen sich natürlich ganz andere Auflösungen realisieren, oder?
Aus der Entfernung hat man natürlich dann entsprechend bessere Auflösungen, klar.
Und könnte das wissenschaftliche Interesse daran sein, noch höhere Auflösungen zu haben? Gewinnt man da so sehr viele neue Erkenntnisse, die man nicht jetzt auch schon mit 50 cm pro Pixel hat?
Im wissenschaftlichen Bereich ist eigentlich die räumliche Auflösung gar nicht so sehr das Interessante. Da spielt eher diese spektrale Auflösung eine Rolle. Also dieses feinbandige Untergliedern in schmale Frequenzbänder.
Aber jetzt so unterhalb dieses Wolkenproblem, das ist ja für den optischen Bereich, das ist ja ein Problem. Das hätte man halt auch gerne nicht. Wenn man so auf Knopfdruck mal sagen könnte, alle Wolken jetzt mal für 10 Minuten weg, das wäre ja schön, gibt es aber nicht. Würde man jetzt mit Drohnen fliegen, dann könnte man unter der Wolkendicke bleiben. Oder ist das auch nur Graufatasi?
Man handelt sich nur ein anderes Problem ein, wenn man mit Flugzeug oder Drohne fliegt, dass natürlich die Flugbahn wesentlich instabiler ist, als sie es bei einem im Weltall befindlichen Satelliten ist, der wegen Luft, Wind und so weiter. Das heißt, man muss dann sehr viel mehr Korrekturen anbringen. Die Technik ist zwar inzwischen sehr ausgereift. Die Kameraanlagen selber sind eben stabilisiert. Und auch die Rechenprogramme sind inzwischen so, dass man vieles sehr gut ausgleichen kann. Das war also vor 20, 30 Jahren noch ein echtes Problem. Sie haben natürlich andere Aufnahmewinkel. Die Aufnahmestreifen sind dann eben auch noch schmaler.
Aber das ist sozusagen die Probleme, die gelöst werden müssen, ist, dass wenn es eine Flugabweichung gibt, dass man die zumindest genau mitbekommt.
Man muss sie mitmessen und hinterher dann entsprechend ins Korrekturprogramm reinsteigen.
Eine sehr feine GPS-Messung zum Beispiel. Beziehungsweise in Zukunft dann vielleicht auch mit Galileo.
Das Einzige, was als Anwendung käme, wäre städtische Region. Dass man die eben wirklich häusergenau und noch genauer kartiert mit solchen Aufnahmen aus Nahdistance sozusagen. Über größere Gebiete, die eben nicht bebaut sind, macht es eigentlich wenig Sinn. Das sind ein Meter wirklich gut genug und 50 Zentimeter.
Das heißt, Satelliten werden auch auf absehbare Zeit im Wesentlichen das Mittel der Wahl sein, um unseren Planeten zu beobachten? Kann man das so sagen?
Es ist inzwischen Standardmittel geworden und hat sich etabliert. Und die Luftbildkartierung im Wesentlichen schon abgelöst.
Was sind denn so die Aufgaben, die eigentlich noch anstehen? Was für Möglichkeiten der Erdbeobachtung zeichnen sich denn für die nahe Zukunft ab, wo vielleicht bis vor Kurzem die Technik noch nicht so mitgespielt hat? Oder wo jetzt auch neue Bedürfnisse entstehen, die bisher so noch nicht abgedeckt wurden?
Es sind im Rahmen der Klimawandel-Problematik hat man diese Hauptthemen, Sicherstellung der Ressourcen. Und darunter fällt einmal die Sicherstellung der Nahrungsmittelressourcen. Da spielt Bodenqualität eine große Rolle und die Grundwasserdetektion. Also hier ist sicherlich einer der Hauptanwendungsgebiete, in dem man versuchen wird, mit neuen Satellitentechniken auch bessere und genauere Kartierungen zu erreichen. Bodenfeuchte ist zum Beispiel ein ganz großes Gebiet, wo man sicherlich mit Radarmessungen auch noch eine ganze Menge Neuigkeiten und mit Hyperspektralmessungen eine ganze Menge Neues entdecken wird. Energieversorgung, da ist ein ganz typisches Beispiel die Standortplanung für Solar- und Windkraftwerke. Was sich natürlich auch mit solchen Instrumenten ganz gut erledigen lässt, indem man einfach Sonnenanstrahlung ausmisst oder Windexposition, Windrichtung, Windhäufigkeit, Geschwindigkeit.
Man kann den Wind aus dem All messen?
Das gibt Laser, mit denen man solche Windmessungen sehr gut hinbekommt. Und das kann man mit Bodenmessungen auch entsprechend eichen. Über der Meeressoberfläche kann man auf jeden Fall mit Radarmessungen die Windgeschwindigkeit und die Windrichtung ableiten. Da geht es eben über die Räumigkeit der Meeressoberfläche und die entstehenden Wellen und Wellenabstände. Das kann man sehr genau messen. Und mit Laser kann man auch Windgeschwindigkeiten messen. Ich kann allerdings momentan nicht genau das Prinzip erladen.
Das heißt, im Wesentlichen ist alles eigentlich getrieben von diesen Fragen. Klimawandel auf der einen Seite und Ressourcenverteilungsproblematik angesichts einer immer noch anwachsenden Gesamtmenge Mensch auf diesem Planeten. Was mir jetzt noch Frage zum Abschluss ist, die Leute, die jetzt so in der Erdbeobachtung arbeiten, gerade jetzt so hier in dem vor allem wissenschaftlichen Kontext, das scheint mir ja ein Feld zu sein, was eigentlich eine sehr breite wissenschaftlich-technische Aufstellung hat. Also so ein Studiengang, Erdbeobachtung, gibt es wahrscheinlich gar nicht, oder? Gibt es so etwas?
Doch, Vimo-Sensing gibt es schon. Wir haben, wenn ich mal bei uns so Revue passieren lasse, was die Leute an Ausbildung haben, eigentlich das ganze Spektrum all der Studiengänge, die mit Geo anfangen. Geophysik, Geologie, Geografie, Geodesie. Dann kommen die Kartografen stark mit rein. Aber was momentan stark bei uns vertreten ist, sind Leute, die aus dem Bereich Geoinformatik kommen. Das ist aus meiner Sicht auch ein Fach, mit dem man sehr gute Berufsaussichten hat. Und dann haben wir aus den Anwendungsbereichen von Forstwirten, Landwirten bis Städteplanern und Informatikern, also das gesamte Spektrum Physiker, alles was sich im naturwissenschaftlichen Bereich tummelt, vertreten. Also wir haben eine bunte Mischung. Aber geoüberwiegt, muss man ganz klar sagen.
Nachvollziehbar. Weil das ja auch immer, wie wir das ja schon eingangs erwähnt hatten, das definiert sozusagen erstmal die Aufgabe. Und dann muss man quasi die technische Lösung dafür finden. Richtig?
Ja, wir sind also gar nicht so sehr technikgetrieben in der Satellitenbild-Auswertung, sondern eher anwendungsgetrieben. Deswegen auch diese bunte Vielfalt der Berufshelder, die hier vertreten sind. Das macht das Ganze auch abwechslungsreich. Man hat immer mit neuen Kollegen und aus anderen Erfahrungsbereichen zu tun und verharrt nicht so in dem monotonen Biotop von vielleicht nur technikfreak.
Aber wo wir noch nicht so richtig drauf gekommen sind, wo ich mir vorstellen kann, dass gerade dieser informatische Bereich auch zunehmende Bedeutung haben dürfte, diese ganzen Datenmengen, die hier gesammelt werden. Wir reden immer wieder mit, naja, man kann ja beobachten und dann muss man irgendwie auswerten. Nimmt nicht dieser Teil der Auswertung immer einen größeren Raum ein? Welche Disziplinen sind denn da? Was muss eigentlich alles getan werden, um diese ganzen Daten dann noch zu beherrschen?
Der Laie stellt sich das immer ein bisschen sehr einfach vor. Der denkt, die Bilder kommen so, wie sie hinterher dann zu sehen sind, auch vom Satelliten runter.
Mit den roten Bäumen.
Ja, in Wirklichkeit kommen rohe Datenströme runter. Das sind erst mal nur Bits und Bytes. Die werden dann zu Bildern zusammengesetzt. Diese Bilder selbst müssen zu standardisierten Datensätzen aufbereitet werden, bevor man sie an Nutzer rausgeben kann. Das heißt, wenn eine Mission geplant wird, dann wird von vornherein schon geplant, welche Datenprodukte entstehen sollen. Da gibt es diese sogenannten Level-0-Daten. Das ist also alles Rohdaten. Material, was runterkommt, wird so abgespeichert. Dann gibt es Level-1. Die haben schon bestimmte Eichungsalgorithmen durchlaufen. Die sind vielleicht geokodiert worden auf eine bestimmte Kartenprojektion. Dann gibt es veredelte Daten in bestimmten Verarbeitungsstufen. All das muss gespeichert werden. Da wir hauptsächlich mit Raster- und Bilddaten arbeiten, sind das enorme Datenmengen, die man auch nicht mehr händisch bewegen kann. Hier haben wir robotgesteuerte Großarchive im Einsatz. Was heißt das? Robotgesteuerte Großarchive?
Hochregallager mit Festplatten drin?
Das ist ein Archiv, das nimmt den Raumhörer in einer kleinen Halle ein, so Länge etwa 10-15 Meter. Dort sind drehbare Silos, Regale, in denen unterschiedliche Datenträger stehen können. Es ist also nicht beschränkt auf einen Typ Datenträger. Vor diesen Regalen fährt ein Roboter mit einem kleinen Greifarm entlang. Wenn jemand einen Datensatz anfordert, dann fährt der Roboter zum richtigen Regal. Das dreht sich so, dass der entsprechende Datenträger nach vorne guckt. Der Roboter greift sich diesen Datenträger, vergleicht noch mal ganz kurz anhand eines Strichcords, der auch drauf gedruckt ist, zur Sicherheit, ob es sich wirklich um den handelt, der angefordert wurde, fährt dann in ein anderes Regal, in dem ein entsprechendes Lesegerät steht, je nachdem welcher Datenträger gewählt wurde, steckt es dort rein und dann wird der Datensatz gelesen und verfügbar gemacht. Der Clou bei dieser Technologie ist, dass ich eigentlich nicht mehr Raum brauche, weil man davon ausgehen kann, dass in bestimmten Zyklen die Speichertechnologie immer fortschreiten wird, immer dichter packen wird, sodass ich dann einfach die älteste Technologie, den ältesten Datenträgerbestand ersetze durch die neue Technik und dann Copy-All mache, das alte rauswerfe und wieder Platz habe für mehr Daten.
Womit man auch dieses Problem der Vergesslichkeit dieser Medien auch gleich mit erschlagen hat?
Das hat man natürlich auch damit erschlagen. Das ist ja sowieso ein Riesenproblem, die Langzeitsicherung der Daten, denn man muss ja eins sagen, der Wert der Daten bemisst sich ja darin, dass ich wirklich Langzeitarchive habe. Ich kann vergleichen, wie war es früher, wie ist es jetzt, und dann diese Change Detection-Auswertung machen, die ja ganz, ganz wichtig ist. Wir haben uns Ende der 90er-Jahre mal dem Vorwurf ausgesetzt gesehen, man würde Datenfriedhöfe anlegen. Aber im Zwischen hat sich die Einsicht durchgesetzt, dass gerade diese älteren Daten ganz, ganz wichtig sind, weil oft überhaupt keine andere Information aus diesen Zeiten zur Verfügung steht. Und das zweite große Problem ist, wie komme ich jetzt an diese Daten ran, die in den Archiven drin stecken? Und da ist eine neue Technologie, die ganz stark im Kommen ist, die webgestützte der Datenzugriff, aber auch die durch den Nutzer selbst veranlasste Weiterprozessierung der Daten, dieses Webprocessing, das angestoßen werden kann. Und hier sind gerade diese vorhin schon angesprochenen Geoinformatiker ganz besonders gefordert, die eben hier völlig neue Verfahren entwickeln sollen, dass Nutzer jetzt nicht nur Daten einfach downloaden können und dann mit ihrem eigenen System weitermachen, sondern dass sie das nutzen können, was auf der Anbieterseite vielleicht an High-Tech-Software schon im Einsatz ist, um dort die Daten schon so zu konfigurieren und vorzuverarbeiten, dass sie direkt für sie passend sind.
Das heißt, man kann dann auch über das Netz auf diese Daten live zugreifen?
Mit der Einschränkung muss ich den Finger gleich heben. Mit der kleinen Einschränkung Beachtung der Rechte an den Daten. Da, wie gesagt, viele der Daten eben lizenzpflichtig sind und kostenpflichtig sind, kann natürlich nur das rausgegeben werden, was frei ist bzw. man muss es bestellen und bezahlen.
Aber wenn ich da jetzt auf der entsprechenden Webseite rumnavigiere, dann schicke ich nicht den kleinen Roboter durch die Gegend, oder?
Wenn man einen Datensatz anfordert, ja.
Ach so, das heißt, dann läuft er schon. Ist das schon so oder soll das in Zukunft so sein?
Nein, nein, das ist schon seit 1995 so was. Ich glaube, seitdem arbeitet der oder 1998.
Aber ich meine jetzt die Abfrage über das Internet sozusagen, dass man ihn live losschicken kann.
Dann man sieht ja nicht, was er macht oder ob er in Bewegung gesetzt wird.
Ja, aber ich finde diesen Gedanken ganz großartig, dass man da irgendwie so eine Information abfragt und die Responsezeit von 65 Sekunden liegt daran, dass dann erst mal ein Robot durch die Halle fahren muss.
Ja, man versucht das zu entschärfen, indem man sehr große Cache-Spreicher dazwischenschaltet, auf die die Daten erst mal zwischengespeichert werden, sodass Daten häufig angefragt werden, dass nicht jedes Mal mit Greifarmen aus dem Regal gezogen werden müssen, sondern dann direkt schon online, wirklich online bereitstellen. Aber im Prinzip stimmt es schon. Der Roboter wird auf den Weg geschickt.
Verstehe. So ein kleines Datenbergwerk, wo dann so Datenzwerge rumlaufen.
Ja, ein Graben. Data Mining. Heißt, es gibt ja auch hier einiges.
Endlich ist mal aufgedeckt worden, was sich hinter diesem Begriff tatsächlich versteckt.
Tatsächlich ist dahinter auch eine ganz neue Technologie. Nämlich neuartige Suchweisen. Wie sucht man nach Daten? Also die Klassische ist ja immer, ich wähle einen Satelliten aus, von dem ich Daten haben möchte. Ich wähle einen Ort aus, von dem ich Daten haben möchte. Und einen Zeitbereich, in dem aufgenommen wurde. Diese drei Komponenten sind bei fast allen Such- und Katalogsystemen verwandt. Eine andere Herangehensweise wäre ja, thematisch zu suchen. Ich gebe mir alle Daten, in denen Vulkan zu sehen ist. Oder gebe mir alle Daten, wo Wald brennt oder Wald zu sehen ist. Oder Stadtgebiete. Und da werden auch Verfahren, dieses Data-Mining entwickelt. Das ist auch so ein typischer Forschungsbereich, der sehr gefordert ist, gerade bei den großen Datenmengen. Wo man solche Algorithmen versucht zu entwickeln, die den Bild automatisch schon mal vorinterpretieren und das dann abspeichern an der Datenbank, sodass jedes neue Bild, was reinkommt in die Datenbank, mit solchen Katalogisierungsattributen versehen wird, die dann abgefragt werden können.
Das schreit natürlich auch nach neuen Standards für diese ganzen Daten. Umso komplexer jetzt erstmal die Rohdaten werden, umso mehr muss man sich natürlich auch darüber Gedanken machen, wie man das dann wiederum verallgemeinert und standardisiert auch abbildet.
Ja, da gibt es inzwischen eine ganze Reihe von Bemühungen, bei Geodaten Standards zu entwickeln, die wirklich international global eingehalten werden. Im Bereich gerade dieser vorhin angesprochenen GMEs-Services hat es im Vorfeld schon einige Programme gegeben, die nur solche Standards entwickelt haben. Also da kann man inzwischen davon ausgehen, dass wenn man sich an diese Standards hält, die dort festgeschrieben wurden, dass dann auch ein durchgängiges Durchschieben von Daten durch verschiedene Systeme über solche standardisierten Schnittstellen erfolgen kann, sodass man wirklich auch neue Software entwickeln kann, die den Standards entspricht und die einfach anpflanzt an das, was bereits vorhanden ist.
Gibt es denn einen international akzeptierten Standards-Buddy, ein Institut, was sich vor allem mit diesen Geogrammen kümmert?
Es gibt, wie gesagt, diese Projekte und ansonsten sind das die ganz normalen Standardisierungs, also IEEE oder...
Okay, also an die Bodys einfach angeschnallt. Ja, haben wir noch irgendwas ganz Dramatisch Wichtiges vergessen zu erwähnen? Meine lange Liste ist fast vollständig abgehakt.
Nein, ganz spontan fällt mir jetzt auch nichts ein, was da noch hätte erwähnt werden müssen unbedingt.
Das ist ein gutes Zeichen. Das heißt, wir haben alles abgearbeitet, alles erzählt, was man über Erdbeobachtung erzählen kann. Nein, das Thema ist natürlich noch sehr viel ergiebiger. Aber ich denke, dann können wir es an dieser Stelle hier auch mal abschließen. Vielen Dank, Hans-Joachim Lotz-Iwen, für die ausführlichen Darstellungen der Welt der Erdbeobachtung. Ich muss auch selber sagen, da ist irgendwie eine Menge Musik drin. Also gerade diese unermessliche Datenfülle, die sich im Prinzip aus diesen ganzen Messungen herauslesen lässt und die ja in sich auch irgendwie unendlich zu sein scheint. Also es ist ja sozusagen nur eine Frage der richtigen Logik und Kombinatorik, wie man dann eben auch die unterschiedlichen Messungen, die man so vielleicht bisher noch gar nicht korreliert hat, zusammenbringt, um wieder ein ganz neues Erkenntnisbild darauf aufzubauen. Das scheint mir da eine der großen Herausforderungen zu sein. Sehe ich das richtig?
Ja, insbesondere dieser Verschnitt von Daten aus unterschiedlichen Quellen, bei dem jede einzelne Komponente einen bestimmten Informationsbestandteil hineinbringt, der aber erst in der Synthese dann zum Gesamtbild wird. Das ist eigentlich das, was die Herausforderung momentan darstellt, dass man Daten zusammenbringt. Nicht nur Daten aus der Fernerkundung, sondern auch Daten, die vielleicht statistischer Art sind oder Daten, die aus Bodenmessungen, aus anderen Messungen bereits vorliegend dann hernimmt. Dieses Zusammenschau ist eigentlich das, was am Schluss das beste Ergebnis bringt. Fernerkundung alleine ist sicherlich nicht das große Mittel.
Vielen Dank und auch vielen Dank fürs Zuhören bei dieser Ausgabe von Raumzeit, dem Podcast von ESA und DLR. Mein Name Tim Pritlove und ich bedanke mich sehr für das hier entgegengebrachte Interesse und hoffe, dass ihr auch das nächste Mal wieder dabei seid, wenn es heißt Raumzeit sendet. Tschüss und bis bald.